foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
oh
yeah
foreign
[Music]
thank you
box
[Music]
thank you
laughs
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
oops
[Music]
this is the final event before the big
tour finals and seven players have
already banked their spots but who will
get the final ticket to Toronto it's
going to be must win today for Jan
pomniacci Anish giri and Maxim not only
to have a chance to go to Toronto but to
make it to the Grand Final in the AI cup
oh my goodness that's a move for you
right there I think this is the craziest
position I think we've seen on the tour
this season
oh my god oh wow
[Music]
he's enjoying himself a bit too much
Magnus my slipped
[Applause]
he's so good he's so good at thinking on
the flight it's over Magnus Carlton he
takes it after an exciting final match
here
foreign
we started the day the tournament with
eight players everyone with two lives
but the player is fighting today they
only have one life left so it's going to
be must win and to guide you through a
dramatic day in the AI cup we do have
the man with the fruity color is on his
analysis board Grandmaster David Howell
and the always energetic International
Master Tanya suchidev and David six
hours in that chair yesterday how did
you sleep well I was buzzing I was
pumped full of adrenaline afterwards I
can only imagine how the players felt
because it was a day of drama maybe one
of the most action-packed days we've
seen so far this season yeah the
Highlight Tanya was the big Winners
final the match between Magnus Carlsen
and maximum what was it about that match
that had had everyone just so excited it
was awesome it was world-class players
playing world-class chess and that was a
reminder for all of us why Maxim is
truly one of the best players for so
many years a speech specialist on his
best day he's on equal ground against
Magnus let's not forget Magnus did not
actually win the match it was still tied
but it was that Armageddon game that got
him the win with the black pieces
despite the draw it was scintillating
chess day three in the AI cup it was a
long day of Chess and not only did it
give us two armageddons and that
fantastic match with Magnus and mvl it
also gave us what was described as maybe
the best and most genius move of the
tournament
the Rooks will be off the board and the
other Rook will find the entry into
enemy camp and it's all happening look
at this he's given up his Rook amazing
this is genius Pawn to C5 just ignoring
the threat on the white Rook because
look at the Black Knight is just too far
away it can no longer control the white
Pawn from running this could be the move
of the door so far wow he resigns
because this white Pawn is about to
promote
yeah there we go it's on the board
Magnus will he Retreat his Queen
as we're expecting the fact paused Queen
sacrifice
Magnus Carlsen surprising us not
recruiting to a passive Square gives up
his Queen and then Maxine gives the
queen straight back that was crazy and
suddenly magnus's Queen side pawns will
run black is too slow in this race and
Maxim knows it he looks away and Magnus
takes the win Maxine resigns wow we have
the first decided game
a rook sacrifice instantly from Maxine
Bachelor
this is crazy this is genius there's
checkmating ideas all over the place one
move now for Magnus Carlson and he finds
it and he finds it in less than a minute
Maxine meanwhile going forward with his
King wow
wow look at this if he pushes his Pawn
will he get mated Magnus Carlsen on the
edge of the board we all know Queen vs
Rook how hopeless that is Magnus allows
a Checkmate on the board and we have on
again
it is a dead drawn position which should
clarify the departure of knights Magnus
gave up his extra Pawn to get the
knights off the board means it's a dead
draw and Maxine doesn't try to flag he
offers the draw and Magnus progresses
after a huge fight between two fantastic
chess players they tied the match in the
rapid portion it ends with a match loss
for mvl in Armageddon
and that means mvl is knocked down to
the losers bracket Magnus today gets a
day off he is straight through to
tomorrow's Grand Final and today it's
all about the loser is bracket first we
have the losers semi-final with Anish
giri against janapomniacci best out of
two rapid games and then the loser is
final where the winner of the loser
semi-final will play Maxim vargielagov
for that second and final spot in the
Grand Final and as mentioned it is also
all about that final ticket to Toronto
today
the easy answer is that for the four
players fighting for that ticket if well
they win this tournament they are
secured that ticket but it's not that
simple and Tanya what is the scenario
for Jana palmyachi how can he make it to
Toronto the three players in the
elimination bracket today the clear part
for them is when did they beat the final
boss tomorrow and you're through to
Toronto but it's a clear path but also
the hardest one to do Jana Palmer she
well he's the lucky one because he's got
more scenarios that work in his favor uh
and uh well to start with if he wins
against Anish today and against mvl it
doesn't even matter what happens in the
Grand Final because he has enough tour
points he becomes uncatchable he books
that flight ticket to Toronto but on the
other hand if he wins only against uh
Anish today he still has a shot he needs
some results to go his way for Jana Pam
Nashi for that ticket to Toronto today
is the big day wow and say aim for Anish
Geary what is the scenario David for
Anish giri that's right Anish giri just
cannot afford to lose if he loses either
match today if he doesn't make it to the
Grand Final he is out no matter what he
needs to win both matches and
potentially even defeat Magnus the big
boss as well tomorrow or he needs to
rely on a bit of help in division two
where he has half an eye on feather
save's results for the save could catch
him even if Anish gets to the final yeah
and we're gonna update you on the
scenario for maxim vaginal later today
before he plays the losers final because
that all depends on what happens in the
losers semi-finals but it is that fourth
player playing in division two here in
the AI cup fed dose
and that's a complicated one it's a
complicated one lots of ifs and buts for
the big fish his best shot is the first
win division two get those 50 tall
points but it still need results to go
his way in division one one thing sure
perceive is not only concentrating on
his game today but also cheering really
hard for Anish giri against the anisha's
match with Yana Palmer Street because
Yan has more points More tour points
than foreign
it's complicated but it's also
action-packed and federal sale is an
important piece in this puzzle he is
playing the winners final today against
the artemiev we will of course pay
attention to the match to finish find
out if he is able to make it to the
Grand Final in division two and have a
chance to go to the tour finals in
Toronto
six events
eight players
we are nearing the end of the 2023
season and the fight to secure a spot at
the 2023 tour finals is on Magnus
Carlson Hikaru Nakamura and nodipek
Andrew sotorov have already qualified
through winning individual events Wesley
so Fabiano caruana alireza faruja and
Dennis latvik punched their tickets for
tour points and now only one spot
Remains the tour finale will be played
from December 9th to 16th in Toronto
Canada
thank you
follow to see who will get the chance to
fight for the 2023 Champions chess tour
title
do you think this means a lot to them
David the players to be able to go to
Toronto with players like Magnus Hikaru
Fabiano that's always a bit of Pride
involved and you never want to miss a
top tournament if you're an elite player
um it's going to be historic this tour
Final in Toronto Gathering some of the
world's best players uh in front of the
fans it's going to be a fantastic
fantastic event so for sure they'll be
desperate to get there yeah and first of
all it's about the losers semi-final for
janapomniacci and Anish giri they have
made it there by playing some fantastic
chess uh Geary for example have knocked
out Hikaru Nakamura and Shakira and
mandirov on his way and napoleonji have
played some fantastic chess but they did
meet on the very first day of the AI cup
and what happened in that one Tanya it
looked like decisive match win for
napoleonchi Jan was dominating that day
and he wrapped that up in just three
games he made it look easy on day one it
was Magnus and Jana pamishi who got that
match win with just three games and it
was not just the scoreline once again
but it felt like Jan was clearly the
more powerful player but ever since then
starting from day two we've seen a
completely different Anish and I have a
feeling that Jan won't be playing the
same Manish for Anish as well there's so
much motivation to get this win in to
make it to Toronto so I think it's going
to be a brand new fight between these
two and at least for Gary He's forgotten
what happened on day one of this
tournament yeah feels like it happened
years ago now it was like a long time
ago but for sure Yan woke the Beast a
niche looks in top form right now yeah
it does but we do know Rihanna she can
play some fantastic chess as well he is
described as one of the biggest chess
Geniuses out there
foreign
[Music]
because my grandpa and my uncle used to
play a lot and of course it was like
Curious what are you guys doing his
friend always was raised because he had
a lot of questions he was very curious
during all school he was very attentive
very serious and of course his favorite
subject in primary school was a chess
lesson because he could play chess very
well at this moment and he explained his
classmates some chess combinations
helped them to solve chess puzzles and
helped the teacher in chess
um
[Applause]
I think there are a lot of brilliant
players but I think the one who sticks
out to me as a genius the most is
probably on the premiere
has I think most people will know the my
opponent for the world championship
match I don't believe in genius to tell
the truth I believe in work as I said I
believe in talent in in his private life
his again lifeful guy he loves partying
he loves social stuff he loves sports
he's both talented and hardworking and I
really think that it's a great example
for all the kids and all the teens in
the world that success never comes alone
well probably more time you spend more
motivated you get yeah because I believe
uh even after I entered let's say the
elite group of players yeah I believe I
crossed this 2700 in 2010 or something I
can't say that I did a lot of Chess work
and just I did a lot of different stuff
and as well like this uh video games and
so on so I was almost almost you know a
semi-pro in in Dota and I had you know a
lot of other Hobbies but you know quite
recently maybe like for that for the
last few years I just
try to focus my attention and my energy
on just work and
try to improve
if we speak about his qualities that
have made him to become the greatest in
the world I think the first is of course
chess Talent then Hard Rock then
extraordinary memory
extraordinary logic of course
extraordinary thinking
extraordinary train of thought
non-standard problem solving and his
ability to focus on the main thing his
ability to calculate situation a few
steps forward
churches
making a fantastic a genius move
yesterday in uh one of his games David
what was this move that we called so
genius yeah it was one of the highlights
of the day certainly one of the
highlights of the tournament it was this
position against farrugia he needed to
win Yan and he pushed his Pawn forward
he gave a poison Pawn to his opponent
vergia took the bait he shouldn't have
done but here was the trick after a
Trader Rook suddenly white is out of
nowhere out of the blue winning he gives
up this Rook which is attacked just
ignoring it pushing his Pawn forward
because if the Rook Falls the pawn out
races the Black Knight the Black Knight
just too slow to stop it and yang went
on to win
is he a genius a chess genius
that has just arrived here you've got to
be otherwise you don't make it to the
world championship match twice right he
won two candidates back to back and uh
definitely it's uh his style of play his
uh ambitious confidence speed chess that
we see even when there's a classical
format and today he's playing against
Anish who needs to keep an eye out on
the clock the first match in the AI cup
that they played Jan would just break
away on the clock so early on have a 10
to 12 minute advantage and that really
came back to haunted Niche so Anish has
to have a better time control in this
match today and he starts off with the
white pieces Anish Gary what is it about
for Anish today I think just getting out
of the opening in good shape that was
one area that normally Anish is really
strong in uh that let him down on day
one of this event in game one of the
their first match three days ago Anish
was just busted out of the first uh game
out of the opening he walked into Jan's
preparation and there was no way back he
just couldn't recover so I think
studying with the white pieces is
actually a good thing for initial area
today he lost twice with black against
Yan on day one he will be hoping to
strike back now all right we are waiting
for the loser semi-final to start it's
going to be best out of two rapid games
only two games on the losers brackets if
they are tied after those two games then
it will be decided in Armageddon who
goes through to face mvl Maxim
vashilagrav in the losers final later
today and here we go the first game has
started here we go and it's a Petrov
defense known as one of the most solid
openings for black uh out there and okay
a quick trade of Pawns in the center and
all the knights staring at each other
now this is really topical stuff this
seems to happen uh it's already happened
this tournament Tanya but it seems to
happen in a lot of uh really Elite games
right now yeah and especially in a lot
of elite games and we see yandere he
seems to be grooving looking very
confident about his opening Jan is known
to play aggressive chess and we've seen
him play the night off so many times but
then there was this shift that happened
in his play and I think it was around
the 2021 world championship match where
suddenly Jan was coming forward with a
lot of more solid openings and we're
seeing him now employ the super solid
and also known as the Russian defense
the Petrov he's got some great results
in this one Anish didn't really managed
to get anything with the white pieces in
their first match against the Petrov I
wonder what he has up his sleeves for
this one yeah and uh look how quick the
players have been firing off those moves
it's move 11 now and a pawn sacrifice
temporarily at least from janapomnishi
remember as Tanya mentioned for the
world championship matches both against
Magnus and against ding this has been
hit the core the heart of his opening
repertoire as black so he's spent months
pure months studying this one he knows
everything there is to know that's why
I'm so surprised her Anish is kind of
playing uh he's walking into the cave
here he's playing in his op his home
territory and okay he takes the bait
white grabs a pawn in the center but
look at Black's Bishops look at the
black queen really active here the White
Queen getting kicked around herself and
I'm not so sure Anish has reason to be
happy here with the outcome of the
opening we see the Queens disappear
white is a porn up but
black is great compensation and that
compensation is all around the piece
activity and the better Pawn structure
that you're highlighting uh David that
A2 pawn it is thunder the bishop on E6
is attacking it but you've got to be a
little careful because taking it
immediately could land you in big
trouble white will simply sidestep with
the rook and then you've got a double
attack to deal with The Bishop's hanging
The Rook is hanging on the other end of
the board so don't get too greedy just
now but it's really not about getting
greedy you could simply move the Rook to
one of the open lines d8 or E8 I like
the square d8 as you're pointing out
it's an open file and like you said
enough compensation all your pieces are
playing A2 is still hanging not really
clear how you keep the compensation and
there we have it Rook today yeah so
we're already in the end game we've
barely played for two minutes and queens
are off all the knights have disappeared
and it is about this Pawn structure if
white can somehow trade off all the
Rooks and keep his pawns intact a niche
will be the favorite but you have to
think that Black's activity right now
gives great compensation It's Tricky the
problem for white here it is tricky to
advance your poor majority you have four
versus three on the king side but you
cannot push yet because of this annoying
pin and therefore your Pawn in the
center is slightly disconnected from the
rest of your army Yan playing super fast
and strange body language there I gotta
say he looks like he's hiding from his
own position but I think secretly he'll
be feeling pretty confident
especially if he keeps the pace going
and he does keep the pace going right
immediately blitzes out that the move
eight six I like it because it takes a
key developing square away from a white
dark Squad Bishop Bishop to G5 would
have been a temple attacking that Rook
that just came out but yeah not only
creating some space around his King but
making sure that a niche's bishops
remain inactive who do you think the
happier of the two players will be after
the opening Tanya the outcome here
it's so level right now and uh you know
as Kai you said it's the best of two so
the margin for error is so little you
perhaps don't want to go all out take
your big chances early on I don't think
either of them are too displaced but
with the black pieces they get this kind
of activity to get the space up on the
clock Yan should be happy probably
happier out of the two with the opening
outcome yeah actually to be honest I
would even take Black's position
normally I'm quite materialistic we've
discussed that in previous days is greed
good uh White is a pawn up but it's just
so hard to kind of find moves here to
come up with natural plans for white
your queen Side Pawn structure I'm
looking at that left side of the board
and White's pawns there they're just
right for the picking uh at any point in
the near future
I think Jan just the fact as well that
he's clearly prepared this opening he
studied it with computers maybe with his
seconds with coaches
um I think that will favor him
when you've played an opening and
prepared it for two World Championship
matches it doesn't get deeper than that
the prepper is at the highest level and
Anish there tries to create some player
on the queen side also dissolving his
own Pawn structural weaknesses Jan
doesn't stop if it almost gets the
feeling as if he knows every single
thing in this position the one thing I
want to point out David it would be
ideal traditional chess wisdom that
decide that you have more Bond on you
want to start pushing them for this one
it's the king side for Anish giri but
for that he needs to move the king from
G1 to H1 to be able to advance the F
Pawn forward just the plan but the
problem with that is the moment that you
move the king the sidestep the king to
that H1 square that black Bishop can
jump over to C4 hit that Rook on F1 and
then the F2 Pawn just becomes extremely
weak so it's really difficult for Anish
to actually capitalize on that extra
Pawn on the king side yeah incredibly
tough right now and okay this is the AI
cup I have a feeling Jan at least until
this last Smith has studied this with
neural network engines we talked about
his world championship preparation any
world championship match the top players
in the world they're looking at Deep
opening Concepts especially when it
comes to pawn sacrifices they're looking
at with computers if the computer says
you can sacrifice a pawn and it's still
playable your position that means it's a
it's a very uh kind of positive
development for you and it is a very
typical AI then what makes you think
it's Ai and not just a normal computer
well we know Alpha zero was famous for
Pawn sacrifices and it's long-term
sacrifices here actually Yan has been
given his Pawn back so he's not putting
down anymore uh black has these double
dope ones but Alpha zero got a lot of
success with long-term Pawn sacrifices
pushing Rook spawns up the board and it
was not materialistic at all and I think
until Alpha zero came along even the top
uh kind of man-made computers like
stockfish they were very materialistic
they loved grabbing pawns uh even if the
rest of their position didn't make much
sense
um and it was AI that uh kind of gave
that human touch it said okay these
positions where it looks like this
compensation they are actually playable
and it looks like one of those cases Yan
doing a bit of a dance here he looks
really happy yeah he's really wiping to
this one because it's so much his
comfort zone and you can tell why you
don't probably even have to be a Petrov
expert you give this position and you
can see the peace activity look at those
beautiful two Rooks lined up for black
on the E and the D line the Bishops in
front of the pawns really active squares
and there are also these potential
tactics based on White's back rank
weakness right now David I'm trying to
calculate the line that if Jan is really
enjoying it
you must be listening to music right I
think the position is music to his ears
right now and the line I was wanting to
point out David is I'm wondering if
Anish actually took that pawn on A5 with
all these uh tactical motives around the
back Rank and Jana actually get greedy
with the pawn on E5 at first you think
rookie 5 is met by a discover check on
eight seven but then you just pick up
the bishop you lose the rook and then
you win a white king
winning the king tends to be a good sign
in any game uh this is a back rank
Checkmate and there's various spins on
this uh Tanya the problem for Anish is
he cannot defend his Pawn in a healthy
way uh he would love to jump out the way
attacking uh this rook and defending
this Pawn but same idea again Rook takes
porn luring the white Rook forward and
suddenly whoops Checkmate and you're
caught
yeah I was gonna say quote unawares here
that's a nice way of putting it this
would be disastrous for white of course
so and each defends the pawn with his
Bishop but White's Bishops are far less
effective than blacks these Bishops kind
of stare at the whole board White's
Bishop especially this one stares at his
own pawn and uh there we go I was about
to say it's going to get hit as well Jan
kicks this bishop away look how he's
just completely uh prevented white from
pushing pawns forward here and if this
bishop Retreats there's now access into
the second rank feels like it's turning
move by move still not kind of a losing
position for white you're still not
significantly worse but momentum black
for sure all right so we have seen young
dancing so far on his camera and I was
just thinking about they have such
unnatural pulses when playing chess like
Denise is sitting like this I would
never sit like this or and Jan was
sitting like this I would also never sit
like this what's it what's it about with
the with the way you eat okay this one
now
this one I would never what is it about
the the pulses that you have while
playing uh computer chess it's uncanny
there Kaya you're like a copycat the way
you could mimic those poses
um I don't know what it is I think
there's a lot to do with psychology a
lot of players um yeah sometimes they
feel the weight of the occasion
therefore they have to prop up their
head
um sometimes I know that for myself and
a lot of top players if we're losing we
don't want anyone to see us so we have
to cover uh we don't kind of let anyone
see our eyes and how upset we are
um there's various poses I'm not sure
because of the reasoning maybe it's just
subconscious but uh every player has
their favorite pose what's yours Tanya
that's really anything that you say
about you know the typical
to make sure that others can't see
what's happening in for me this is how I
would usually sit but it's only so I
don't get distracted by what's happening
Beyond both and over the board and
online yes so um mostly an over the
board player I only started playing
online with the pandemic so uh yeah over
the board I feel that you always find me
like this and it's to kind of cut out
and block out the world
but what about sitting like this
just why can't they just sit like this
uh chess players I know they have back
problems sometimes because uh leaning
over the board too much at least in my
case uh my favorite pose is just arms
crosstalk oh the Death Star oh Fierce oh
very nice yeah yeah yeah I've never seen
David do that because we've never played
a little bit and I've seen you at
tournaments this is true I bet like if
you actually worked with like a mental
coach or something I bet that mental
coach would actually say it also depends
on how you're sitting across your
opponent sit with confidence I guess it
must have something to say definitely
confidence Poker Face uh sometimes
actually scaring your opponent with like
kind of eye movements like Nakamura does
sometimes like just the shock uh I know
that when I played at the World Cup
recently
um the Wang Hao the the Chinese
Grandmaster who knocked me out uh I
would play literally a forced move it
was check I have no other legal move
other than moving my king and suddenly
he's like what
wow tactics though here Tanya not
reacting to the threat on the white
Bishop he's recaptured this is really
risky from inish Gary but I think he's
worked it all out and look at Jan
suddenly his eyes widen he gets more
interested more excited about the
position so he leans back forward and
covers his mouth covers his face a
really interesting sequence of moves
because with that uh Pawn push G5 I
think we should do a little Deep dive
here because uh Jan came in with the
attack on White's Bishop on F4 when he
played the move G5 and I think what
Anish didn't like about just going on
the defense with that Bishop is then
Black's Bishop falls back defend the
defends the A5 Pawn The Rook jumps into
D2 as you're pointing out and that a
pawn can eventually end up creating a
lot of trouble for white so Anish going
for a very concrete approach our fans is
the best defense in these kind of
positions when you've got to be careful
so he does take the pawn on A5 hits
Black's Bishop in return Jan falls back
with the bishop so both players playing
with Tempo Now The Rook is attacked
you've got to move it to a square where
you can attack another piece Anish falls
back hitting the other Bishop now and
that's when we saw that reaction from
Yan because he's got some options David
right now where to move with the bishop
if you fall back to B5 continuing with
the theme of attacking The Rook I think
Anisha slides over with the Rook one
square and now we can see that balance
is restored once the the Bishops are
captured yeah it's like a little dance a
little Tango between the white rook and
those black bishops the black bishops
finding nice safe squares but not quite
in time uh to win White's Bishop I don't
think a trade here would be helpful for
example and uh okay we see a trade in a
different scenario will now Yan go for
this tactic you mentioned Tanya I think
he can take this Pawn uh no reason not
to right now it might look like this
bishop check jumping out the way is a
discovered attack but remember this
would be a blunder King takes Bishop
walks into uh now for white a background
Checkmate yet again and it's on the
board Rook takes E5 so this is a pin
slightly awkward right now for initial
I'm expecting him to break the pin uh
the most natural way to break a pin is
to defend the kind of the piece that's
pinned at the back here that's the white
Rook so shuffling the king across
there we go it's played really nice call
that you've got to be on the defense you
need to break the pin on the spot
because potentially F5 was a big threat
winning that Bishop if you did not guard
that Rook but David now white is
threatening to go Bishop to eight seven
the Discover check wasn't possible
earlier but with no back rank weakness
it is so black perhaps doesn't have time
to get into activity with Rook D2 you
really want to come in with your Rook
but I think this fails to Bishop 87 now
yeah it looks like black is about to
deliver a mating attack but Bishop takes
uh Bishop two H7 and this time there is
an escape Square for the white king just
in time you don't want to run into the
eye line of the white of the black
Bishop but you can run to the center
still a complicated position but
certainly not
advantageous for black anymore and
I can I think it's a really important
point if black tries to re-establish
this pin white can step The Rook forward
and just in time after the pawn steps
actually a few ways to break the pin now
if you want to be really flashy you can
even give a check and black cannot take
this bishop because the Rook takes Rook
this shows all of the tactics we're
showing now all of the tricks uh this
shows that it's still rich full of life
despite the fact a lot of pieces a lot
of material has disappeared right now
and it's opposite color Bishops actually
this line on the board ah
still in driver's seat I think Jan is
playing for the initiative here he's the
one with the more active Bishop the more
active Rooks putting the pressure but
again the big Eternal question of Chess
is it going to be enough
what do you think Tanya I'm gonna get
there first because
I think it's going to be a draw
yeah David um we're good friends I'm not
going to disagree with you in this one I
think that despite the fact that Jan is
putting the pressure one gets the
feeling that too many trades have
happened the opposite color Bishop game
one most likely to end in a draw okay
which will be a good start for both of
them and but there will only be one more
rapid game to win the match if that one
is a draw as well if this is a draw then
it will be decided in Armageddon I think
odds are big we will see some Armageddon
in the two matches today okay imagine
the fate of a whole season one whole
year leading up to this to a finals
settled in just one Armageddon game the
shootout uh to The Bitter End that would
be brutal yeah and they will probably
then put a lot of thought into their
time bits if we do see Armageddon yeah
and uh the opening choices everything
that would be dramatic do you think
they've even already sort of made a plan
for what they will bid if they do end up
in Armageddon
interesting possible because it's just
the best of two right so uh there is a
big chance of actually going into that
so at least to have in mind a sort of a
general strategy do you want to play
with the black pieces how low are you
willing to go for those black pieces uh
the time bit because we saw that play
quite a big role in the armageddon's
that we had yesterday uh so I wouldn't
be surprised if it's something that they
have given a thought yeah it was
interesting to hear Magnus in his
interview yesterday he said his opponent
Maxim ashlegrath due to his mathematical
background had clearly done some
planning clearly done some research onto
uh kind of where the best kind of time
to bid uh is or kind of the the bounds
which are kind of acceptable that
maximize your results and yeah Maxine
there went over 10 minutes so it's
really interesting
and Magnus usually is so good at getting
into his opponent's heads and we've seen
it throughout the tour right he's almost
able to predict what his opponent is
going to bed but yesterday he wasn't
against magazine because he mentioned
that he could have actually bid for two
more minutes on the clock so he kind of
missed the mark by quite a lot really
interesting to see that but it will be
if if in the grand final tomorrow we do
see Armageddon again with Magnus he did
sort of hint that maybe he wants to copy
mvl later because he thinks Samuel must
be with his mathematical background
really good at those time bits that will
be interesting yeah maybe mvl watched
that interview though and then the Mind
Games he knows Magnus is going to call
his bluff so he might Bluff and go lower
Yeah by one second oh it's always fun
with uh Armageddon and Jana poniacci in
this one thinking now for three minutes
what is that about I think it's purely a
dilemma now how to keep the game going
if all of the Rooks disappear from the
board because it is opposite color
Bishops the game nearly definitely going
to end in a draw white will hold the
light squares black will hold the dark
squares and no way I kind of passed each
other but while Rooks remain there's
always some chance and the problem for
black is you need to keep as many Rooks
on the board as possible and you need to
start pushing the a pawn Black's main
kind of Ace upper sleeve here right now
is the a pawn uh so the problem is if
you start pushing it white will move his
Bishop away Rooks will disappear from
the board and if you kind of switch your
attentions to the other flank white
white has some targets there White's
Rook on the fourth rank attacking
Black's F Pawn
so I think he's just debating how hard
he wants to push for a win here
interesting move really mysterious move
I've got to say this last one and a
slight Shake of the head from Jan yeah
I wonder if the shake of head is just
him taking his time and kind of
realizing that he's gotten everything
that you can with the black pieces in
the Petrov but maybe there's nothing
more to be done because now if
if both pairs of Rooks come off the
board it's a draw because it's an
opposite color bishop and for a niche
it's very possible that he just Retreats
with the bishop and at least I get one
uh pair of Rooks off the board the other
Rook on C4 which will remain is quite an
active Rook I like the move that you're
pointing out because that Rook to C4
also hits the pawn on F4 and you end up
trading one a rook on the e-line a
bishop F3 has been played I think Yan is
just uh sort of getting ready and
accepting that he didn't get much out of
this opening and Caillou mentioned that
a draw would be a result that both
should be happy about but I think it's a
bigger draw for yeah now just a slightly
better draw for Yan uh in a best of two
the next game he starts with white
yeah he should be happy I don't think
the shake of the head is anything too uh
to kind of read into there
um the outcome of the opening was great
as black that's the problem sometimes
you play a great game a fantastic
opening and if your opponent as white
sets up a solid defense it's hard to
break through yeah
it's so harsh on himself that's the
issue I think maybe that's held him back
in his career just just he doesn't let
go of mistakes and he hasn't made any
mistakes here Tanya I think it's just
been a level game throughout it really
has and do you think Jan is somewhat
similar to Hikaru in that Mano with the
Expressions that they give out and how
unguarded and unfiltered they are I
think maybe Hikaru plays more for the
gallery than genuinely has these
emotions going through his head he will
have them in over the board as well
definitely I mean we saw it against ding
it was just heartbreaking to watch when
things turned against him in that
tiebreak Jan yeah he was just overcome
and understandably when the stakes are
that high and again this takes her
extremely high in this battle maybe
that's why the emotions building and uh
yeah Anish meanwhile trying to stay calm
looks very calm yeah
and yeah we keep looking at their
cameras today another thing I noticed
and now we know Ian is in a hotel room
he's in the Netherlands but very often
you will see beds behind players they
often play chess in bedrooms I guess
there's like offices and guest rooms and
stuff like this and interrupt me if if
we should talk about the move but isn't
it kind of strange that your job and
earning like thousands and thousands of
money playing this tournament it's in
your bedroom
it's the most comfy place in the world
yeah we're lucky yeah if I could choose
my job again yeah I would be a child
player you just never have to leave your
bedroom yeah one of my favorite things
was uh in the play-ins for one of these
tournaments this season
um we have these extras these second
cameras set up just to monitor players
and uh I did see one I won't name who it
was one player he was lying in bed the
laptop was balanced on his belly and he
was just playing and he was winning
loads of games it was incredible but
yeah I mean you've got to play where
you're comfortable yeah sometimes that's
the bedroom yeah yeah I agree with you
and I think that's why when the pandemic
hit and the whole work from home
happened it wasn't that big of a change
for chess players because we've always
been working from home
in pajamas pants and maybe no pants what
do I know family friendly showcase those
questions for the interviews later are
you wearing pants today
who might be about to see a draw uh we
have seen this position now already this
is the second time we've seen this
position if the white king goes back
towards Black's F Pawn the black Rook
moves away I think uh we'll see the
players agree to piece very very shortly
not really many ways to kind of avoid
this right now I think it's inevitable
there we go the white king goes forward
Black's f-board is about to drop
it's only black who can really play for
a win here but
how do you improve your pieces the black
Bishop totally stuck right now Black's a
pawn kept under watchful gays from the
white rook and blacks Rook just tied
down as a Defender if it tries to
activate on the D file we'll see Gary's
king drop back and the position will
just fizzle to that repetition to that
draw it's ending in a drop but I want to
point out one Dynamic that exists in
this one David that white has to watch
out for don't get too greedy with that
F4 Pawn you've been pointing out this
eight barser that black has and let's
make a move for for black that while you
can't really defend the alpha Pawn but
let's say you go King to G6 on the board
quick call David the prophet and if
white takes an F4 I think there are
dangers in this position and the bar
does drop because black can just start
pushing the a pawn and after A4 White's
Rook is pinned on F4 the bishop and G4
is doesn't have enough time to come and
actually fight against the passer yeah
no way to stop it you can only stop this
Pawn on a light square and the white
Bishop cannot get round in time uh to
block it all these squares that it wants
to use are covered so that would have
been a huge huge trap
napoleonishi still looking for tricks
this is why the top players in the world
are so strong but of course giri uh
plays a more practical move he's going
to blockade the pawn on a light square
and this is where the opposite color
Bishops comes into play the blockade is
impossible to break once your opponent
owns a certain color complex and okay
the black Rook comes across at least
he's asking questions still he's hitting
this bishop but uh this this move should
clinch the draw now Rook to C6 really
accurately this is a pin the blackbrook
now guaranteed to be traded off and the
key difference from your line Tanya is
that the pawn cannot March so this one
will be a draw yeah very precisely
navigated to safety by Anish this one
but for Jan I think he's got reasons to
be pleased starts with the black pieces
absolutely no problem out of the opening
and kind of gets a draw on his terms
yeah it's always a moral Victory
psychological uh win to put your
opponent no pressure to be the one
asking the questions and not once in
this whole game did it look like black
was ever in trouble whereas for Anish he
he was the one avoiding things uh
dodging pitfalls
this game we'll see it lock up just get
completely blocked the problem with the
black is there's no way into the white
position with his King
and uh giri will just sit passively and
wait
yeah and how cool is it that we've got
this uh elimination bracket today and
the three players who are in it each one
of them is fighting for a spot to
Toronto and the only way that they get
there is by making it to tomorrow so
this is It's almost like a script that
you can't write if you sat down at the
start of this tournament and predicted
this it would be really hard to get to
this point yeah and here we are here we
are and it's actually going to go down
all the way to the final day of the last
event before Toronto yeah it's
incredible yes you said we couldn't have
written a better script for it it's not
just these three players it's fair to
save in division two somehow he's made
it this far it's pretty much everyone
who can get to that sport in Toronto has
brought their a game this tournament and
uh they're really pushing hard to make
it there and that's how much they want
it yeah and uh as Tanya mentioned uh
before this game started for feducev and
division two
um most likely he will have to win
division two he is today playing the
winners final and uh two games have been
played now against blood is love our
time ever they are tied two draws so far
best out of four games so we will keep
an eye on that definitely and that's a
tough one our time yeah is such a strong
player it's not gonna be easy for photos
here today yeah it's going to be tough
and he has to win today maybe
potentially win tomorrow as you
mentioned Kaya yeah uh so for the safe
work to do
this time yeah and these two as uh well
definitely Anish giri he has to win this
match and uh well so does
everyone is playing today it's all about
winning today you just have to win today
it's must win for all the players and we
love that
but this game probably not a win for
anyone it's a draw probably yes yes this
one will end in a draw the one script
that we could have written at the start
of the tournament is that whoever wins
today will meet Magnus Carlson in the
Grand Final that's true that's true it's
been on fire lately third consecutive
Grand final four minus crawls how
impressive is that yeah I think it's
just those rest days he loves those rest
days and you get one on the fourth day
of every tournament if you keep winning
that's what motivates Magnus and
meanwhile we see some pawns disappear
but it doesn't change anything here
white has a full blockade of Fortress as
we call it no way through for the black
king it
anything
with which Jan has even handled this
draw position is really impressive he's
just gone Max on Ultra Pro Max on the
whole thing but it's not enough you do
everything but White's Bishop is
stopping the A3 Pawn the king defends
the king side and we do have a result it
is a draw
we have a draw game one is finished and
you carry out the white pieces in this
one
no big reaction but only one rapid game
to go where he will have the black
pieces so do you think a niche is not
too happy with uh how this game I think
how it started and the pressure that Jan
managed to create out of the opening
Anish should be happy that he navigated
it precisely to a draw and to safety but
yes I think he was hoping for more with
his only white in the best of two so
that's that mean he's quite happy now
and he has nine minutes now to prepare
for a game with the white pieces yeah
you couldn't tell it from his face he
couldn't tell it from his camera his
Expressions but I think deep down he
should be quite content he did beat Gary
twice with white uh on day one so it's
going to be an uphill struggle I think
for Gary yeah one more rapid game to go
in this match in the losers semi-final
now don't miss out on September you guys
through the end of this month claim up
to 30 of all new Subs on Twitch
subscribers gain access to exclusive
break time content during broadcast and
scoring ad free experience on chess.com
so don't miss out on the deals this
September describe now everyone and
don't go anywhere we'll be back in a few
minutes with the final rapid game and
the losers semi-final foreign
[Music]
much but neither would a Sicilian
Defense to the untrained eye this is a
performance enhancer you don't see it
how about now manage your air quality
sharpen your performance change the game
with air things love playing chess
variants or just looking for something
new join us for the variants Community
series
every two months we'll be featuring a
different variant in a series of events
and competitions learn a new variant and
compete against other players for prize
money or just play for fun look for
Community Arenas streamer Arenas and
Championship events six weekly Arena
tournaments held every Thursday will be
followed by a championship event with
cash prizes including a one thousand
dollar first place prize the third and
final weekly Arenas will be streamer
Arenas featuring gifted Subs as prizes
when any of these events to qualify for
the championship the variants Community
series kicks off on September 7th with
King of the Hill we're the first to
occupy the center wins the game but
getting checkmated still loses and join
the variants club today to learn more
about upcoming events how to participate
and much much more see you in the arena
on chess.com
it is must win today foreign
they draw they drew the first game one
more rapid game to go will we see a
winner or will we see Armageddon in the
fight to go through to the losers final
to be played later today against Mexico
this is the AI cup and we're also
excited to announce that at this
tournament chess.com is partnering with
the browser maker Oprah we are thrilled
about this collaboration it is something
for chess lovers everywhere it truly
puts the game right at your fingertips
no matter where you are imagine that
your very own chess browser and using
Oprah's AI tool Arya we did interviews
with the players before this tournament
asking Arya to give itself out as uh
Anish giri
so first of all thank you for taking the
time to do an interview with chess.com
but I have to tell you we actually
already did the interview with you using
Oprah's AI engine Arya we asked it to
answer questions asked Anish giri and
are you ready to be confronted with your
answers
yes yes uh definitely all right so first
question was uh who is your biggest
inspiration and you answered my biggest
inspiration has to be the legendary
chess player uh Gary Kasparov
wow so far so good yeah yeah I think I
would have said the same actually what
is your favorite time control my
favorite time control is classical time
control I think it's the one that had
the best results in uh probably by
probably by faraldo hard to say if I
think of my style I would expect myself
to be
strong and Rapid but somehow the results
yeah the results don't show the same I
guess it's because yeah I've been sort
of focusing on classical for just much
much too long what is your favorite
opening and the answer was if I were to
choose a favorite it would be the real
Lopez
I I think the AI wasn't fed enough of my
tweets where I'm constantly promoting my
neither of course and then we ask who is
your biggest rival and the answer was
players like magnet Carlson Fabiano
cariana and Vladimir kramnik have been
formidable opponents and have
consistently challenged me in
tournaments and matches
wow yeah it's uh I mean it's a decent
answer because
um I've played with these players a lot
of games
um so yeah good uh good answer there but
a little too too generic I think what is
your ultimate goal in chess My ultimate
goal in chess is to become the world
chess champion
yeah
generic but in this case it works very
well I think that's the
you know uh for me I think that's the
ultimate goal have you reached your Peak
as a chess player the answer was I
believe there is still room for further
growth and Improvement in my chest
career would you agree
[Music]
sort of improving a suggest player for
sure
but it's extremely challenging how would
you describe your personality so I'll
sum up it says compost
analytical ambitious diligent respectful
and Sportsman's life and with a sense of
humor
yeah I mean the I hope they're
respectful and Sportsman's like was not
the sign of of the humor
but very very
yeah a flattering answer which is also
which is also a fitting because I'm not
modest and I didn't mention modesty what
is your IQ
and the answer and I hope you can give
us the correct answer the answer was I
don't have a specific IQ score to share
with you but I remember I once had an
online test that I wanted to to do I
don't know why like probably some kind
of spam came and like some maybe like a
10 minute IQ test it's very very nice so
or 15. so anyway very short sized uh
decided to complete it and it went
pretty smooth and I got I think like 139
yeah wow and it said like
um so it said you know okay you are this
good great you know smart all that and
it showed that if you are above 140 you
are genius
another 139 I think okay
hang on a second let me do one more
because I just want to cross the 140
right I mean that's all like who doesn't
want to cross these things yeah so um I
did one more 136 came out I did one more
138 cameras I did one more 133 137 came
out 139 I kept doing them it was already
late I couldn't cross the 140. whatever
I do whatever I do I just cannot be a
genius
what is the best thing about being you a
niche and it answered one of the best
things about being me is the opportunity
to pursue my passion for chess at the
highest level chess is not just the game
for me it's a way of life
oh very very cool very cool uh very nice
I I'm a little surprised it limits the
answer to chess only you know I would
probably give a more General answer as
well you know to have a family myself
now and all the friendships and you know
this blah blah I would mention for sure
do you know who hacked your Twitter
account
and let's see if it gives an answer no
it says well it's quite an unfortunate
incident that my Twitter account was
hacked as of now I don't have specific
information about the individuals
responsible for the hack yeah that is
true I did the this uh police report
back then and I guess they treated it as
like just like another bike theft yeah
so it means nothing nothing came from
that awesome thank you for answering
Anish you just got Aid
well a little bit up and down for Arya
there I'm not sure if it's quite ready
to uh take over for Anish giri answering
questions for for him uh but doing quite
a good job and talking about AI the
trophy in the AI cup is a AI generated
this is the trophy and it's up for bits
you guys then you can place your bid at
the chess champs.io I think this is a
really cool trophy actually and talking
about trophies we want to have a
competition today we want to give out
some something really cool we want to
give out David Howells granu Grant like
a Grandmaster book and you can win it
if you caption this and share your
caption using chess Champs on Twitter or
X
caption this do you have an immediate
caption Tanya
oh my gosh I'm looking at that it's
scary
um yeah grind like a grandma
nice one just looks like something from
Halloween yeah yeah I can't wait to see
some of the answers and the price if uh
the win the winner with the best caption
we will choose one by the end of the
show wins uh David's brand new ground
like a grand master book signed by
Magnus Carlsen himself and it should be
signed by you as well David that's right
I have a copy of the book here I did
trick Magnus into signing it the other
day he uh very kindly signed as you can
see just here so I'm gonna try and sign
it as well and uh do you want to do it
live yes okay it's just a little message
never
stop oh grinding like a grandma
there we go and a signature
I want this book now ah okay yeah there
we go signed by both of us fantastic
this fantastic book with two signatures
by two fantastic Grandmasters is up for
grabs for the winner of our competition
the place you are captioning on hashtag
uh using hashtag chess Champs on Twitter
Anish giri well he loves tweeting but he
has to play some chess right now and uh
he has to win or at least not lose this
final rapid game in the losers
semi-final against the happy piano
he is finding his uh Rhythm grooving to
some music today on the palmyachi this
will be game two the final rapid game
and the losers semi-final if we have a
winner in this game that player is going
through to the losers final to face
Maxim vagina Ralph just after this game
if it is a draw then we will see
Armageddon here we go Yana ponachi with
the white pieces here we go uh Anish in
that AI interview said his favorite
opening was the Sicilian night off but
he's gone for the Berlin defense a rock
solid opening here I haven't seen Anish
employ this too regularly in recent
times and Jan does not go for any Force
draws we breathe a sigh of relief the
Berlin of course known for that instead
we see a slower variation and this last
move point of C3 is quite rare I believe
Tanya a slower variation of the
anti-burling here by Jana bamashi so
still keeping the game alive I think
there's an approach by Anish to go into
the Super solid Berlin it it's a clear
indication that he wants to now get to
the Armageddon he's happy with the black
pieces to just not get into any big
fight any big duel where Jana pamushin
his aggressive style can Thrive but yeah
I'm not letting it go so easy so we
still have a game on our hands and Anish
falls back with the bishop slows down
does that surprise you it does surprise
me firstly because Yan went for this uh
kind of Bishop for Night Exchange then
played this rare move on the last turn
Pawn to C3 and uh to kind of pause after
one of uh one of the most natural moves
for black is slightly strange he's
looking off to the left or his left uh
janaponishi there that often means
players are in recall mode just trying
to remember his opening Theory here for
sure it's something he's prepared before
maybe for even for a world championship
match but it is Yan's style to play
quickly confidently in the opening to
try and uh kind of assert his dominance
over his opponent just to scare him when
these two met a few days ago Jan played
so quickly as white I think after 20
moves of the first game he had over 15
minutes now the fact that he slowed down
is not a positive sign for him
yeah I agree with you David and that
also so early on in the game and let's
also just remind everyone that for a
niche
door points are not going to be enough
if he loses this match he's out of
contention on the other hand for
janapanushi today is actually the
biggest day yeah if he wins both his
matches he's through to Toronto he wins
against a niche he beats Maxime later on
and that's all that he needs to do if he
wins this one Kaya he still has a big
chance even if he loses later but he'll
need some results to go his way yeah
yeah that's true this one is it's
especially dramatic for Anish giri yeah
well yeah as well they just both have to
win this one that's just how it is it's
easy they just need to beat several
world-class players in a row uh they
cannot afford to lose any game oh yeah
tough situation to be in of course and
eventually he does make a decision not
b2d2 I want to praise the niche as well
for being really flexible clearly this
was his plan the Berlin defense uh
coming into this game because this
Sicilian did not work out for him on day
one of this event against Yan he got hit
in the bishop B5 check Sicilian a couple
of times uh struggling out of that
opening and good wisdom for anyone if
you're struggling not liking the
positions not enjoying what your
opponent is throwing at you switch
things up in the next game often that
gives you a new a new lease of life and
it keeps your opponent guessing keeps
them surprised and Anish he plays a
really ambitious move actually he brings
the black Bishop out a more solid player
or someone kind of less inclined towards
attacking like me might have just
castled the black king that would have
been a safe move of course but he's
keeping Yan guessing look how the black
king uh once the black queen moves out
the way it can actually choose either
flank to Castle on he's waiting it's a
bit of a kind of guessing game right now
he's saying depending where white puts
the king I'll choose which flank I put
my black king and then we might even see
Mutual attacks but first Yan goes
hunting for the bishop here black has
the two Bishops
due to an earlier trade and normally you
don't want to allow your Bishops to fall
especially Black's light squared Bishop
which is the better of the two
black as the bishopper white has the
more flexible Pawn structure so I would
definitely agree with you that for Anish
it's important he's already doubled up
the seat bonds to actually keep retain
that Bishop advantage that he has two
moves come to my mind here for Anish uh
head in hands right now Bishop can fall
back to D7 but David that's a square
that you perhaps want your queen on at
some point to allow that Queen side
castling that you were pointing out or
you could get more aggressive with black
in this position and go all the way
forward to G4 and he reaches out for his
mask and he does take a decision he's
going aggressive mode Bishop G4 hits the
queen and Yan immediately answers with
Queen to B3 attacking B7 Anish Returns
the favor with getting his King to
safety defending that F7 Pawn that you
were just highlighting but there is
another Pawn hanging in the situation
yeah and the big question now it's
actually a critical moment quite early
on in this game both players have slowed
down Queen takes B7 can white get greedy
evaluation Bar says no but from a human
perspective it's not immediately clear
whether refutation of this move lies
you've won a pawn it's a very important
Pawn as well because black is left with
a wreckage of a structure uh isolated
pawns doubled pawns all over the place
more targets but white is temporarily
behind in development so Tanya do you
see what was wrong with this he didn't
go for this he first kicked away the
black Bishop This is complicated stuff
it's really complicated I don't see a
direct way to actually trap white screen
or to get to it but I think it's about
the initiative again in this case it
could be about the initiative
but uh it's all about development right
all of Black's pieces are playing white
doesn't have the possibility to go
castle with the King because then the
bishop would jump onto E2 attacking the
rook and the pawn on D3 the queen on B7
vulnerable even a move like Queen to D7
defending the C6 Pawn comes to mind and
the valbar doesn't like it to me it felt
like a natural approach here
yeah David not sure then what is the
exact repetition to this yeah I did just
check there and this is actually not an
obvious move so credit to both players
for spotting that this would have
actually favored black The Retreat
Knight to D7 it's all because this
Knight is hanging white loses time
having to retreat it or defend it and
then suddenly the Black Knight would uh
leap it would pounce and this queen is
lacking squares note how this Pawn is
suddenly undefended as well this would
lead to huge trouble for white because
after Queen takes Pawn your queen
actually might even get trapped and uh
here we would see the queen doing a
dance and the pawn falling and White's
King in Mortal danger so instead of
greed here Yan wisely decided to hit
this bishop first and the question is
does Anish play Safety First chess uh
retreating this bishop back to it start
Square would no longer Gambit this Pawn
but the more ambitious move of course is
to keep the bishop on an active post and
maybe the same tactics maybe Queen takes
B7 still met by this idea of Knight
dropping back and night leaping that's
actually an awesome tactic that you're
pointing out you to go forward on the
next move loose pieces drop drop off and
full board awareness right you're trying
to get to the queen on B7 but also
hitting the Knight on the king side and
another weakness at the center of the
board so just covering All Points there
really nice tactic uh in a
counter-attacking way making sure that
the B7 Pawn is defended to your first
earlier question about the bishop
Retreat I do like the more active
approach here keeping our keeping it on
this H5 D1 diagonal and the reason I
like it is David because if white was
ever to go castling then the idea that
we pointed out earlier is always in
there with the bishop jumping to E2 so
it's still not very clear uh for an for
Yana pamelishi how would he get his King
to safety yeah and Anish is going
through all the poses right now on the
camera I think he wants to play the
active move of course but he's
meditating first
gotta do what you gotta do he's using
the force just levitating the mouse the
pieces with his mind
but I'm expecting that move for just
like you there Tanya active play
nearly three minutes though thinking
about this one move the punishi seems to
be getting a bit Restless rocking back
and forth in his chair and eventually
giri takes the safe approach the bishop
not a happy camper retreating back to it
starts where but at least now there's no
tricks White Queen cannot go hunting for
Pawns and black would gained some time
back by kicking back the white knights
in the next few turns Mind Games I think
they're Tanya wow look at that the
bishop and then the night Retreats with
the idea that you pointed out the bishop
and C1 is defending the Knight on G5 so
it's not hanging but not knight from D7
is landing on C5 in the next move so
taking advantage of that Queen placed on
the queen side which is a bit vulnerable
and at some point Anish has the F5 break
in mind to try to open up the position
open up the king side and get more
activity against the White's on Castle
King yeah
throw pawns for it I know many attacking
players would love that especially Anish
if he gets the opportunity if he feels
that Jan is taking too many Liberties
leaving the king in the center too long
it might just be time to Castle I was
going to say but he drops his Queen back
first that's preempting an attack now
the Black Knight will not be hitting the
White Queen will not gain time uh so
yeah just very logical play and the
question is does Black start kicking
back White tonight's now for example
this Knight can be forced back maybe
this Knight can be forced back later or
does black Go Active start trying to
break out
really really in the balance right now I
think it's a level position but the fact
that the pawn structure is slightly uh
asymmetrical here means that chances for
both sides but moving two pieces
backwards there for Anish gear is that a
bad sign for him usually it would be I
think this is one of those scenarios
where it's okay and that's because the
center is mostly blocked if the center
of the board is open you don't have the
luxury of time you cannot just Retreat
your pieces because your opponent will
be able to kind of thrust pieces forward
but if the scent is blocked
kind of Tempe uh kind of move by move
it's less important okay that's why
White's King at the moment is safe
enough in the center because all those
lines are closed
um so yeah Pawn structure determines
everything if it's locked then you can
slowly maneuver your pieces around even
retreating sometimes you've got to go
back to coming forward and that's what
Giver is trying to do is there a chance
Jan won't Castle is King
definitely uh there's a chance he could
Castle on either side still he's trying
to keep his options open
okay now he trades a knight for Bishop
now it's opposite color Bishops again
still nights in the mix I think he will
eventually Castle kingside okay
or not seems to be the answer there wow
that's an aggressive move you is opening
up his King before he's castled has he
forgotten this isn't the king's Gambit
Jan of course famous for that opening
he's played it a lot recently the king's
Gambit is pushing this Pawn forward on
move two uh throwing it away basically
giving up a pawn for open lines and he's
trying to do the same here but uh he's
really keeping a niche guessing the last
time Jan played King's Gambit it didn't
go his way it was in the SCC against
Magnus Carlsen a 17 move lost for Jana
Pam Nashi with the white pieces in the
king's Gambit similar ideas are breaking
in the center but definitely David as
you say it's not move number two so it's
a better position like that and I think
as you pointed out earlier the king
might be headed towards the queen side
now yeah I'm really surprised Anish let
the white Bishop develop so quickly and
so easily to such an active Square
because now white is kind of really
quick here white is going to Castle
queenside on the next turn knowing Yan
and okay this is anisha's idea he's
fighting fire with fire white through
the F Pawn forward black through the
Fawn forward and the position is
exploding
it's exploded because white really
doesn't have any time to get the king to
the safety the last move played by Anish
also threatens to open up the Rook which
is lined up lined up against White's
Bishop so Pawn takes Pawn in the center
is a big threat right now uh which is
why Yan gets his Bishop back to safety
David I get the feeling that this uh
very aggressive approach by Yan with
that F Pawn moving forward without
finishing his development good backfire
it really could but it's uh kind of time
as being of the essence right now for
Anish giri if white gets just one more
move and castles very healthy position
for white so can he strike while the
iron is hot does he have a way to take
advantage of this unique opportunity
just this one move before White's King
darts the safety
interesting intense
and Anish giri is burning time on his
clock we know Jana ponyachi is extremely
good at speed chess
maybe a little bit better than Anish
giri when you get down to those bullet
times
they're both really strong in speeches
but I think you're right if Yan gets a
lot of time Advantage which we saw him
get in their first encounter at the AI
cup uh it usually doesn't go well for a
niche but clearly Anish has things in
control in this match both these games
he's done good time management and now
Anish takes the decision to actually
create a weakness in the center I like
it not only opening up the F line for
the Rook but also making sure that Jan
is stuck with the long-term weakness
that pawn in the center has got no best
friends it's a lonely Bond
wow but there's a sacrifice on the board
it looks like a sacrifice it isn't
actually Gary playing for tactics and he
looks proud of himself he looks pretty
pleased Danish uh on the camera right
there he leaned back he was kind of far
but you didn't see that one did you but
wow that was out of the blue Tanya that
was a surprise
why isn't it a sacrifice really yeah and
uh let's just jump in because it has
suddenly exploded as we mentioned the
position uh it looked here like it's
just about the structure White's Pawn in
the center uh might Advance forward at
some point but at the moment it's
isolated giri said I don't care about
long-term strategic stuff I'm gonna take
this pawn bishop takes Pawn Again full
board awareness and it's not a sacrifice
because the bishop can be taken yet it
would lose the night this night would no
longer be defended White's Pawn on G2
was the glue and it was overworked there
so uh Jan reacting instantly he did not
uh want to part with his Knight of
course so he castles Queen side looks
like like he's crashing through on this
Pawn right now but Gary instantly reacts
throws his Pawn forward and still this
weird position uh of the black Bishop
will it come back to haunt Yuri he's won
a pawn but he's won a Pawn on a line
that opens up the white Rook Harry the H
boards disappeared but that only opens
lines towards the black king yeah it's a
Pawn on the side why your king is and
that means more attacking opportunities
for white so I don't even look at look
at it as a bond blunder by Anna Palmer I
think this is full full compensation
here and he moves the bishop hitting
that Rook this has to be not the ante
Berlin but the anti-est Berlin I've
never seen a more non-berland position
in my life I mean this is just blown up
yeah how often does White Castle
queenside in the Berlin it's extremely
rare and to see the opposite flank
castling and open Center normally the
Berlin is very blocked or it goes
straight to the end game and right now I
like White's chances I think with the
extra time it's Yan's type of position
as well very Dynamic if the bishop drops
back to a bad Square then suddenly we
could see for example Pawn takes Pawn
black should not capture back now
because look the queen will pounce and
it's a double attack Checkmate is
actually threatened on G7 that will be
the kiss of death check mate again and
uh this bishop also loose so suddenly
the stakes are really high one error and
this could end wow that has to be really
accurate to survive wow and I don't know
that much about the Berlin but I often
heard it hear the word boring when I
hear Berlin so if this is very uh not
really like must mean we have a really
cool game ahead of us now it's for
landertainment on the board with the
white pieces we see first the opposite
high castleing and also the fact that
white is down upon but so much so many
attacking possibilities against the
black king it's just all about whether
Jana banoshi will find the time to get
his Queen to join the attack and right
now Anish has to save the bishop so he
decides to move it to the square that
you were pointing out the active square
but now he has to be careful but it
looks like Anish has calculated his way
through he immediately stops the threat
that you were pointing out not allowing
the queen to join the party on the king
side from that G6 Square yeah but if we
look at the two kings right now the
White Queen of course will move out of
the attack from Black's Bishop but if we
compare the Kings uh here we go the
White Queen moving towards that King
side black has no Defenders around
Black's Knight is on the wrong flank
wrong side of the board the Knight
actually should be a Defender and
White's King meanwhile there's no
attacking pieces around it so it feels
pretty safe and Chaos could be happening
on the dark squares here Tanya big Chaos
on the dark squares not only squares for
white to jump into but also notice how
those g786 bonds are actually big hooks
for sacrifices that could Arise at any
moment and I was talking about Queen
joining the party it very well is ready
for a big party with that square on G3
Queen to G3 doesn't only hit a mate in
one uh David but also the idea that H1
Rook then threatening to jump in with
Rook 2860 let's not show that and now if
you try to defend this mate there are
these ideas of Rook from H1 because of
the pin on G7 this would be game over
the other Rook joins in on the H line
and that's goodbye to the black king So
Queen G3 is actually a big threat on the
board and even if I'm not really sure
what is the right move here for defense
you can't capture on D5 but let's say
David you try to get a piece into
defending uh the G7 Pawn either Rook 2
F7 or queen E7 one of these three moves
I think now as well white can jump in
with you just take the pawn hit the
queen and win so maybe Queen to E7 to
demonstrate the point that I want to
make here then you come in with your
queen to G3 I'm also threatening Bishop
to D6 in certain positions and notice
how the black king can't really sidestep
a pin if you go to h8 hey guess what
you're still on the pin reptix 86 would
win the game
where to hide a niche now in some
serious trouble on the board and the
clock five minutes down facing a
blistering attack and even if there is a
narrow path to survival it's going to be
hard to find it with the clock ticking a
huge threat of Queen to G3 if we compare
the Bishops we talked about opposite
color Bishops when you're attacking when
there's major pieces on the board it's
all about who has the initiative and you
just can't defend your dark squares I
think you might need a miracle now Anish
giri if he wants to stay alive in this
tournament and in the hunt for Toronto
wow
and the clock is ticking down for any
she is uh getting on the four minute
Mark and the position is just starting
to get dangerous for him to survive this
one he doesn't have to find just one
good move he probably has to find a
sequence of good moves 10 good moves and
with just four minutes on the clock uh
that's its incremental pressure which
makes you collapse at some point this is
going to be a tough task and I think
Anish is regretting capturing that H
Pawn opening up that H line for Janna
what makes the scenario even scarier for
anishes that he's playing a player like
Yan yeah and he's playing with less than
four minutes now on the clock you can
see it on the niche gear he is getting
stressed out right now he knows he
cannot lose this game and it's danger
zone right now and he finds a good
defensive move after a lot of thought it
cost him quite a lot of time there but
now he's aiming to meet the White Queen
landing on the G file with the black
queen blocking so he's ready to
potentially trade Queens if the Queens
disappear in this middle game or this
position then he's safe okay so I think
that's a very clever idea he's aiming to
stem that initiative uh that we saw
earlier and uh yeah I was I was gonna
make a joke that actually he wants to
take that pawn that he captured with the
black Bishop a few moves ago he wants to
give it back to Yan he's saying close
the H file Please block your own room I
shouldn't have taken it because taking
ports open-ups lines for your opponent's
pieces but this is at least a good
defensive move it's a super cool
defensive move it was so natural to put
the queen on that E7 square but a niche
of course this is why they're the best
players in the world he finds and I
think perhaps the only move to keep uh
still a chances alive to hold this on
and the idea is simple that you're gonna
challenge white screen on the G line you
want to play the move Queen to G6 if
white does go ahead with the plans that
we've been talking about Queenie it is
very resourceful by
anishi desperately wants to keep the
Queens on then I suppose definitely and
I'm expecting him if he's feeling
ambitious maybe to push maybe to trade
off pawns and for example here to start
bringing his pieces into the game
whether that's the white Rook uh whether
that's this white Rook uh he can enter
kind of on the other side of the board
with the White Queen he just needs to
kick Queens on no matter what if he
wants an attack and okay he's really
calculating something now head has gone
all the way down he's disappeared
but just like a magician's trick will he
be able to uh conjure something up on
the board it's looking really tense this
does feel like the critical moment
that's why Anish spent so much time on
the clock that's why Yan now uh spending
time back and he knows that if two or
three moves go in Black's favor there's
no more chance this is uh the time to
strike if he's white he senses an attack
and you've got to be sensing an attack
in this position all your pieces are
directed towards that black king you
have a really strong central deep on as
well uh but Anish meanwhile also very
very focused and I think that's so
instructive because you have to use your
opponent's time to think and calculate
as well in these complicated positions
uh the trouble is far from over Anish
has navigated correctly for now with
this last queen move but he needs to
keep up that Precision for the next
couple of moves and that's when it gets
uh more difficult David I really like
your idea of keeping the Deep on alive
it just feels as if that can be used as
another Target to get into black scam so
imagine combining an attack on the king
side and if you can make a move like D6
is D6 possible because for me it's the
most attractive option in the position
yeah it's uh definitely the most
ambitious the most logical here
postpones are there to be pushed as we
say and this would create a really nice
passport it's gonna paralyze Black's
pieces long term it's going to mobilize
them I guess the only downside is that
black snipe will be an easy blockader
and it also gains time against this
beautiful white bishop and if you have
to start retreating we talked about it
earlier Kai you said retreating is it a
bad sign now that the center's exploded
yes it is for both sides so as soon as
white starts going back with his Bishop
I'm not even sure where then suddenly
look at this it's black with the
opposite color Bishops crushing through
the light squares and suddenly it's the
white king that's going to face a
checkmating attack this is how quickly
things can turn if you're just careless
for one move if you have to retreat for
one move and uh yeah this Pawn push he
wants it it's desirable but maybe not
quite uh the right moment for it
I like this uh just this idea of getting
rid of White's best attacking piece
one of the most amazing things about
Chess are these dynamics that exist with
opposite color Bishops so everyone just
thinks if it's opposite color Bishops
the games would usually end in a draw
but actually if the Queens do stay on
the board and as I say they have come
off the board but when they're attacking
possibilities these are the most
dangerous kind of positions because the
different color complexes you just
cannot challenge the bishop of your
opponent which means bigger weaknesses
on this Quest and even though the pawns
are off the board I think that white
Bishop on E5 it does have a solid Target
on that pawn on G7 and Yan is still
ambitious about his chances okay so even
if the Queens are of janaponia is not
giving up winning this game definitely
not and uh it was all predicated on just
one move if white wasn't able to start
attacking look how active the white
Rooks have suddenly got uh if white was
one move slower then the Queen's
disappearing would have most likely
meant a quick draw but white does have
the initiative now uh I nearly said
initiative again you've got it in my
mind Tanya but uh White just has enough
time to start attacking things White's
Rook on the sixth round custom targets
especially Black's pawns on the queen
side over there and yeah the black
Bishop is the key piece right now and
he's trying to eliminate it he's trying
to kick it away and you can go for a
bishop for nitrate here if you're a
niche giri but suddenly you're bereft of
your best piece Black's light Square
bishop and White's Bishop clearly
superior to the Black Knight you have to
be really careful which pieces you keep
on the board
still attacking despite the absence of
Queens yeah and I want to say negotiated
but it just doesn't have the same
meaning
but yes he I think he had to give up
this bishop for this night not a happy
choice because any other move would
probably end up with a big attack on the
G line or you end up losing the C6 Pawn
Ayan will recapture and notice how that
Rook from H4 actually defends a very key
Square the C4 Square so black doesn't
have the time to jump in with the Knight
to C4 hitting that rook in the bishop
because of that last multi-purpose move
by Jan Rook to H4 so that was a really
nice touch there and black just doesn't
have enough time to capture on F3 it's a
free Pawn but it comes actually at a big
hidden cost I think there are all these
attacking ideas of white jumping in with
the Rook a rook to G4 I was also
thinking about Rook to G6 but Rook G4
looks really strong as well David
because black really can't push the Jeep
on the 86 Pawn Falls anyway
and this would be disaster for the black
king even with Queen's off the board
White's Rooks and Bishop combined so
nicely uh so Anish he found a way to
take this Pawn first he uh hit the white
Bishop I expected the bishop to drop
back it did indeed and after Rook tape's
Pawn now at least the black Rook will be
able to cover the seventh rank he'll
cover some holes and we could well see a
race scenario where white takes this
Pawn at some point I'm not sure whether
now or later and it will be a case of
the black pawns pushing but the white
Pawn is pushing on the opposite flank
and here the bishop is better when
there's pawns on both sides of the board
the Black Knight is not a happy piece so
I think white still has a practical
advantage and it's better because it's a
long range piece so you can not only
assist your own pawns on one side of the
board but also stop your opponent's
pawns from advancing while the Knight
finds it difficult to jump around
quickly and that's the this is the key
difference with what Anish has done
getting both Rooks into the game now he
has a possibility to drop both of them
to the seventh round to defend G7 so he
can start with Rook to F7 or the other
Rook moving forward and when white
doubles up on the G line doubling down
on that pawn Anish has another Defender
coming into play yeah he can just about
hold this square and eventually we will
see that situation of white taking upon
not sure which one and uh the game
heading towards that end game race
Bishop versus knight that's the key uh
kind of question right now it's the
Eternal question of Chess right Bishop
was his Knight that's why chess is so
rich I mean they're worth the same and
in different positions one is always
superior to the other but yeah it's it's
so hard to choose it's a matter of taste
but actually in certain positions
objectively one clearly dominates there
was always a debate about the night
actually being worth two and a half
points and the bishop worth being three
points so what do you think of that
conspiracy theory and I was gonna ask
Will that maybe even happen now with AI
who I think prefers the Bishops yeah
especially when they're uh as a pair and
I remember reading this book it was like
10 years ago so before AI really started
taking over but it was about computer
just in general and it said that even
then computers which were slightly
weaker they gave Bishops 3.25 and
knights were three and I was like okay
but humans aren't really gonna think
like that but uh I think it definitely
it was a case of computers ranking them
slightly higher but positions like this
I think that Bishop is worth four and
the Knight is only worth three that type
of uh that type of scenario look how
strong White's Bishop is uh anchored by
a pawn as well and it would be huge
right if if there was sort of a rule
change in chess where you did change the
point system for the pieces I mean the
last rule in chess was that on passant
probably and that came back in when like
16 and 17 years exactly the modern rule
of Chess came uh three 400 years ago
maybe yeah yeah don't quote me on that
I'm not the best of the chassis story
someone needs to tell us when was on
passant uh created a long time ago
before we were born yeah so if they
changed this point system yeah it would
be a big deal absolutely and even if not
officially I think with the computers
and AI playing such a big role uh I
think from a human perspective we often
see that actually in play already but it
all again comes down and boils down to
the kind of position that we actually
have I mean in some of them the night is
just so much more powerful than the
bishop but in this one I agree with
David that that's uh that's a big Bishop
a big small night oh big Bishop in the
center of the board for Iana pulmonary
question is will I give him the victory
in this game
and in this match or will we see Arma
get on do you see chances for a niche to
win this game at all it feels like a two
result position uh position position now
if you look at Black's pawns they're all
separated it's really interesting that
Yan had a choice of which Pawn to take
he chose to eliminate Black's H Pawn uh
White's Rook on H6 Untouchable because
of a pin and that basically showed that
he wants to take risk out of the
position we showed some races where
black had connected pawns and those are
scary once they start marching I'm
expecting Jan here to start retreating
some of his Rooks and long-term Black's
isolated pawns the fact that all of them
are lonely without friends as you called
them uh earlier Tanya it means that they
will be easy pickings potentially later
for those white Rooks and still some
counterplay black has got everything
covered right now one Retreats he's
going to push the Black Sea Pawn to kick
away White's Bishop but I do fear still
long term for his chances I was
find that David I wanted to see Yan to
go for those Queen side pawns and to see
that race because it just felt like
that was anyone's game and perhaps the
bishop could potentially be stronger
than the Knight but look at the way
Anish has handled this in the last few
moves we've been talking about a big
Bishop versus a small Knight that is not
a small night anymore a White's Bishop
has been thrown back uh to that G1
Square while Black's Knight is the one
in the center of the board it's a kraken
as Peter swiddler will would call it
controlling so many key squares yeah and
there's a trick in the position this big
Bishop is no longer big it looks really
small and timid here in the corner but
you cannot go and take this Pawn it's
not a free Pawn it's a trap this would
allow a night Fork suddenly the Black
Knight which looked terrible uh is the
superior piece and
um that means if you cannot take this
piece maybe you have to guard against
the Knight jumping in anyway this looks
like a scary check the white king not
entirely safe if you uh for example
Retreat to a bad Square uh then suddenly
this check would be devastating all
sorts of forks in the air and especially
with the clock ticking you don't want to
blunder but Jan's gone marching with his
King oh wow he started matching his King
forward while the Black Knight dances to
the other side of the board and we
talked about how these were isolated the
white king is going to be the one
attacking them we did not expect this
it's a bit of a turnaround Suddenly It's
all of Black's pieces that are so active
and I think it comes down to Jan's
decision of grabbing that H Pawn look at
that the Anish trying to actually build
that initiative that we keep bringing up
right now if there's a check on the
A-line it's check and mate if for
example black can ever bring a rook up
this would be trapped this white king
promise at the moment and possible
White's Rook covers the sixth rank no
root in towards it seven seconds
furnished and he goes for this trade I'm
not so sure about this one uh pieces off
the board okay he's backing It Up by
trying to go for a pincer movement again
well my iris against that white Pawn
which has just moved off B2 this one is
really livening up it's just a rook end
game though no more debate Bishops
versus Knights and uh Anish is just
trying to trade off as many pawns as
possible maybe even going for the white
king if given an opportunity
and that's upon sacrifice but one that
Yan should be hesitant to take because
that would create so many weakness on
the c-line that blocks active Rooks can
start targeting which is why again wants
to keep the pawn structure intact and
for now it's safe the king is safe the
pawn structure looking good once again I
think uh this one David going to end in
the draw Armageddon is coming up is my
prediction do you think so even with
anisha's clock nine seconds yeah I'm
less confident I would take I mean I
would definitely take white here because
you have two connected past pawns black
has two separated pawns and uh the
absence of both pairs of Rooks gives a
little bit extra spice and also the
clock
we've seen players even the best players
in the world collapse under time
pressure and Yan is extremely good at
maneuvering these types of positions
Armageddon no Armageddon Kaya you gotta
break the tie
everyone get on but I am very excited
about the next few minutes now because I
can feel the tension for Anish giri here
with eight seconds fighting for his life
in the tournament and his chances to go
to Toronto three seconds for a niche
three seconds and now it's a mutual
March of the pawns who's going to be
quicker in this race even the evaluation
bar slightly confused there is heading
up in White's favor and that's simply
because the white pawns are so mobile
they can push blacks Pawn is blockaded
and look at this in the punishes pinning
down the black Rook on the seventh rank
reminding him he has weaknesses there
it's so hard to play five seconds it's
not much time and the pawns are rolling
and it's just so much easier to play
with white radio moves are so much
easier just keep pushing the pawn
meanwhile what's happening don't do
anything oh I think he's just losing
weight can he continue pushing the pawns
I don't think it's a direct blunder I
think it's just a continuation of small
inaccuracies here but look at this Yan
is just marching forward the pawns are
unstoppable the white king is coming in
and the seatbon definitely has a really
good friend with that beep on he can
just continue advancing uh with C6 and
black has to find a way to stop it
the king comes in all forces ready to
assist that sea Pawn from queening you
can give a check on D7 and continue with
C7 but now a trade of Rooks and white
can offer a second trade of Rooks Rook
to C4 he's blockaded the vision of the
black Rook now white sea Pawn is going
to become a queen it's guaranteed and
Geary with no time on his clock gives a
check a spike check white has got this
in the bag it's going to be game over
any moment Jan is bobbing his head here
Anish knows it Anish knows this is these
are his last few moves in the AI cup and
it's over
wow dramatic game that decides the Fate
for Anish giri he is knocked out of the
AI cup
janapomniachi makes it through two the
loser is final to face Maxim vashiella
Bravo that's gonna start in not too long
and has hope to go to Toronto to play
the Champions chess tour finals is alive
it is over for Anish he will not be
going to Toronto he is knocked out after
playing some fantastic chance over the
last few days in the tournament it is
over for a niche with only seconds on
the clock he lost game two and the
losers uh semi-final kind of feel a
little bit heartbreak for Anish after
playing some fantastic chess over the
last few days it really was uh he just
showed phenomenal player against Hikaru
against alireza winning to do or just a
combative play and even today the first
game he gets he navigates his way second
game almost a draw has it in his hand
but it all came down to the clock again
now where Jan had those extra minutes in
a very critical end game yeah
yeah so close but those are the margins
that this uh this level Jan in the end
just better nerves slightly better speed
and that counted that was decisive and
was a dramatic ending to the game let's
take a look at it David yeah let's show
where Yan was able to initiate the grind
in the end game and convert it into the
extra point it was here that anisha's
final chance slipped away he needed to
go active with his Rooks right now the
black Rooks are purely passive he needed
to give away the pride and joy of his
position the G Pawn he needed to move
away hoping that white would capture
because suddenly the black Rooks go in
and double up on White's asset here the
bead Pawn if this Pawn disappears a draw
is guaranteed instead he went passive
putting the black Rook on a bad square
and as we saw Yan started pushing his
pawn and in the final position this was
about to become a new Queen
makes it uh through to the losers final
it's uh gonna start in about 10 minutes
I think where he will face
uh that's going to be intense as well
the winner of that goes obviously
through to tomorrow's brand final who
did not hold us a favorite in that one
mvl against nepo it's such a tough call
and both these players again
entertainment guaranteed for chess fans
and for us in the studio I think we can
expect some dramatic moves even though
they're both aggressive very differently
aggressive while Max seems uh attacking
plays very calculation based that we see
more intuitive faster play by Jana
palmerjee it's gonna be a big fight
David just going back to this match that
we just witnessed right now I also think
one of the key moments that Anish will
come to regret is grabbing that H Pawn I
think that's where it turned around yeah
sometimes greed isn't good and uh Harry
the H porn let them stay on the board uh
suddenly the initiative turned and it
wasn't just the fact that he struggled
to survive on the board it was the clock
he bunts so much time after making those
kind of risky decisions and Jan in the
end I think that was part of his plan he
gambited and it paid off wow wow that
was uh only the first match of today we
do have one big match left today on the
losers bracket it is
to decide the losers bracket and who
goes through to tomorrow's Grand Final
don't go anywhere we'll be back in a few
minutes foreign
[Music]
today
four years chess kit has had lots of fun
online events but it's finally time for
us to go IRL in real life puzzle
competitions a main event and all sorts
of other fun things to do announcing the
chess kid National Festival
come along you'll need fun Master Mike
there
I'm going to the chest Good Festival I'm
going to the chest get festivals
[Music]
fun Master mic that you saw there is
actually the one who taught me that the
queen always wears matching shoes with
her dress and everyone join us in
Charlotte North Carolina for the first
ever chess kid national festival book
your tickets now for four days of Chess
festivities including over the board
tournaments and opportunities special
guests like Gotham chess and fun Master
Mike and also Chief chess officer Danny
wrench the festival takes place February
16th to 19th and we can't wait to see
all of you there
we can't also wait to talk to Anish giri
unfortunately now knocked out of the AI
cop how are you Anish
yeah it was an unfortunate match I had
High Hopes I had some sort of addition
because one once I remember Magnus he
wanted to meet me in the final and it
was a few years ago it's the adjustable
Masters I think and uh in that
tournament I you know I delivered so I
felt you know maybe there I was destined
to get there but somehow the match was
not going well it was better than the my
previous match with Jan but
slowly learning from my mistakes I need
to lose a couple of more times to him to
to get better yeah how about after all
so yeah hearing Magnus yesterday saying
that he really wanted to meet you
tomorrow in the Grand Final so how much
did you want to get there also thinking
about that ticket to Toronto
well as I already mentioned before like
a lot of things had to happen for me to
get there and uh okay a few things did
happen in particular my match with
Hikaru of course was not um not
something anybody would expect uh I
think Shakira is an opponent uh you know
I can sort of lose to but be it as well
on any day so I think that is not less
of a shocker but
yes I mean I had to win against yand and
against Maxim and I think the since I'm
coming from a loser's bracket I think
against Magnus it would be like a match
with some sort of odds it was really
really far
um but speaking of Toronto you know the
there are there are more events uh
hosted in Toronto
um in the near future so maybe I'll
qualify to some sort of Toronto anyway
so I'll work on that very nice and Anish
well you played some really really good
chess over the last few days especially
what are you the most happy about
uh well obviously I'm happy to beat
Hickory because you can count these kind
of Victories on your hand Palm or how
they say that I haven't beaten him in
matches often I did it I think only once
before
um but you know I'm happy to to show a
good level
um
I've had uh sort of unfortunate at the
beginning to the tour this this season
because at one time I qualified to
division one I couldn't make couldn't
play it and the other times I didn't
make it to division one and you know I
felt that okay um
you know I I should be able to to be one
of the one of the guys at least once and
here I sort of played all right
um
but you know just players uh in
particular after uh they lose they can't
stop thinking about their last game so
right now it's kind of really hard to
think about what I'm happy with uh but
surely there are many things I'm happy
with in the tournament some good games
for sure
um in particular making the division one
you know that's that's really nice
because uh yeah that wasn't easy I I won
my last four games in the preliminary uh
which I wasn't even expecting or
counting uh on that I was sort of having
my usual kind of qualifier you know when
it's tough you play the strong Grand
Masters
um you know the usuals uh who are all
the time sitting online playing and when
you face these people in like World
Blitz or Rapids uh it's not so scary but
when you play them online they're so
skilled and so used to the environment
that it's hard uh but then suddenly I
started winning a game of the game so
that was yeah I think mostly I'm shocked
by by the way that I qualified to the
prelim to the division one because this
kind of tournament The Knockout I've
played them many times and I know that
if things go my way I can win a match or
two that's not nothing new but yeah I
think qualifying through the Swiss kind
of tournament with all these experienced
online players that's something I I uh
I'm maybe the most proud of in the in
this event yeah always a pleasure Anish
to have you in the tournament and to see
you play and always a pleasure to talk
to you thank you for joining us
thank you and for the upcoming
interviews with me you always got that
AI uh if you need something exactly I'll
just use that a niche just use that
please
relieving your media do this but I'm
still getting that I'm still getting the
pay right the fees too of course of
course yeah yeah okay then that's fine
okay thank you good deal good deal very
nice honey thank you for joining us
that's it Anish Gary is knocked out of
the AI cop but it continues you guys we
still have the losers final it's
starting in only a very few minutes we
have to go through the scenarios right
now so Maxim can still make it to
Toronto he needs to win his loser is uh
final match to have any chance
and if he beats Napoleon
he will need to win the Grand Final as
well for Jan napomniacci now what is the
situation
he if he wins this he's in he's true uh
he's already done half the job for the
day he's gone through with his match
against Anish he beats Maxim he it
doesn't even matter what happens in the
Grand Final against Magnus tomorrow he
beats maximum
is in to Toronto but for Fellowship the
other player in division two uh David
he's rooting for a player in this match
yeah but the save is cheering for mvl
right now the only way fedesaf can
qualify for the tour finals is if mvl
beats janapomnishi so uh feather save
he's still playing his game uh he's in
the lead now but he's got half an eye on
this one for sure
it's in division two playing winners
final right now he is in the lead
against blood is uh slavartame he leads
by one point they are now playing game
four the winner going through to uh the
Grand Final in division two so Federal
staff is still in the mix but hoping
napongiachi will lose this match against
Maxim
who played some fantastic chess
yesterday in the winners final against
Magnus Carlsen so even if he lost that
match against Magnus yesterday as we see
the tale of the tape between these two
it's very equal can you get any closer
in a rivalry basically the same age both
born in 1990 basically the same
chess.com rapid rating and deadlocked in
their head-to-head scores that is just
incredible this is literally too hard to
call so who do you guys hold us the
favorites I ask you first Tanya it's
such a close match to call uh Kaya and I
hope this one goes down to the wire and
we get an Armageddon I'd love to hear
what the chat thinks about this there's
both Jan and Maxime have played
fantastic chess in the AI cup I mean
that match Maxime versus Magnus
yesterday is one for the history books
and then Jan as well showing dominating
performances in his victories in the
elimination bracket uh it's gonna be a
close one so yeah tell us chat who do
you want to see in Toronto definitely
will it be magazine
or will it be on the palmyachi winning
the loser is finally on the palmyraji
coming straight from the losers
semi-final with a smile on his face and
who do you hold that's the favorite in
this match David this is tough I don't
really want to pick a favorite but I
suspect maybe neponishi is feeling uh
more confident it depends how much uh
yesterday's match against Magnus took
out of vashilograph if he can maintain
that form then I'll back him if the
tightness kicks in or if that kind of
loss in the Armageddon haunts him then I
think the publisher might take it riding
on a high from beating Gary but we're
off it's another Petrov defense and
vashilograph obviously not uh taking too
many risks here he's going for a solid
variation popularized by Magnus Carlsen
where the Queens come off early and uh
this is surprising uh Queen's coming off
means we're still in the middle game
just Queen's uh disappearing there but
it's gonna be slow it's gonna be
strategic
no fireworks in this one at least not
yet I think Maxine wants to play with
the handbrake on he doesn't want to take
any risk whatsoever and uh remember
everyone it's best out of only two rapid
games here on the losers bracket only
two rapid games to decide the losers
final if it is tied then obviously Arma
get on to decide who meets Magnus
Carlson tomorrow in the Grand Final and
maximum I mean he must also even it was
a very long match against Magnus
yesterday but he played some great chess
do you think he's feeling confident
heading into this even if he lost that
match I agree with you I think there are
way more positives from that match than
the fact that he actually ended up
losing it in that Armageddon where
Magnus because of the result odds goes
through into the Grand Final I mean what
a performance it was by Maxim also
coming back in that match after losing
game three winning a fantastic game
against Magnus in game four so uh he's
got to be feeling confident about his
form throughout this event meanwhile
Jana bamashi he sticks to the recipe he
chose the Petrov with the black pieces
against the niche work to Perfection
he's doing the same against Maxim one
important Dynamic that I feel right now
is that Jan's already in the rhythm of
playing today right he's played a match
against the niche and he's won it Maxime
has just come into it and David what do
you think this approach by Maxim to
trade off the Queens go into this
risk-free end game is it just about
getting into the Rhythm and the flow of
the games right now I think that's it
and he's also hoping that Yan might be a
bit tired uh remember Jan in the
interview yesterday said this week has
taken a lot out of him he's played two
tournaments within a week he's gone deep
into this one as well it just seems to
be game after game after game and
um that works in two ways either you'll
you kind of lose energy at the critical
moments or you're in the flow and uh for
vashilograph yeah it's an interesting
opening Choice still looks like a usual
kind of typical thematic position for
this opening but the absence of Queens
means it's all about maneuvering right
now and the one thing I will say Magnus
Carlson popularized this opening Jan
napomnishi played the Petrov against
Magnus so he studied this he's looked at
all the details the ins and outs he
should know how to neutralize uh White's
small initiative here and for sure
Maxine would have prepared this as well
knowing that Yan is playing the Petrov
and it is his pet opening that this is
something that Maxine was also expecting
well we see some rerouting of pieces it
almost feels like a queen last middle
game to me because you still have both
the Rooks on the board none of the minor
pieces have been traded off for
symmetrical Pawn structure but we're
going to see a game of manures yeah a
game of Maneuvers and the reason here we
say white maybe has a small symbolic
Advantage at least the superior chances
is because this Pawn on F3 controls the
scope the jumping squares of this Black
Knight it doesn't look like much but it
does also mean that white is more
flexible to throw pawns forward on the
king side for black pushing these pawns
would come with more risk and I'm
expecting white now to deal with a
threat on this night whether that's to
retreat the night or maybe to retreat
the other night to block and white
suddenly it will be throwing pawns
forward against the black bishops look
how poorly placed this Black Knight is
it can never jump and it might later
have to retreat if it wants to re-route
uh uh towards fresher pastures uh small
thing but from the games of Magnus I
think we've learned that there's enough
life here it's only one set of pieces
that have been traded after all and
Maxine Bachelor of how will he maneuver
it's not kind of a type of position I
associate with him but
at least he knows the plans he wants to
push these pawns if he gets both of
these two moves in the near future white
will be better more space on the king
side that's why after the Knight
Retreats Jan instantly uh pushes his
Pawn to cover the G4 Square no advances
on this side of the board and now I'm
pretty sure that he's happy in the
punishing he's barely spent a minute on
his clock and he's prevented White's
main ideas
really nice uh give white one more move
get that jeep on rolling and you're
talking about a lot of space and
flexibility and movement of the pawn
structure on the king side yeah not
allowing any of that we just shows this
understanding in these Petrov openings
right he knows exactly what plans to go
for and what plans to stop for his
opponent now one of the drawback of that
last move was that it kind of weakens
the G5 square and Maxim immediately
takes advantage of that develops with
the bishop to G5 potentially targeting
that Knight on F6 threatening uh a
destruction of the black pawn structure
which Yan isn't allowing falls back with
his own Knight and you very
interestingly pointed out how the white
Pawn on F3 takes key squares I think Jan
wants to do the same push his own Pawn
to F6 uh kick that Bishop take control
of the central squares and also locate a
key Square for the king to land on F7 to
finish development yeah we see symmetry
in the pawn structure on the queen side
we might very shortly see complete
symmetry on the other flank as well and
this game looks like it's fizzing out
already Jan was again looking confident
as if he was dancing to the music a
moment ago and I think he feels he
solved all of his opening problems and
remember for these World Championship
matches where he's training this opening
he will be playing practice games
against world-class Grand Masters he
will be looking with AI with top engines
with top computers uh at the plans the
kind of squares for his pieces so yeah I
wouldn't be surprised if he knows
exactly what's going on right now or if
he's seen something similar and there we
go he moves instantly he plays the move
King to E7 defends his Bishop with his
King because we're headed towards the
end game because so many pieces are off
the board you can get away with this I
don't recommend it normally because
kings in the center can be targeted by
Queens Rooks Knights but here still safe
for black and Black's King will actually
have a nice parking space a nice parking
lot for that King on the D6 Square once
the dot squares dark squared Bishops
disappear
you know really accurate play by black
defending everything so far
snacking on something yeah we also saw
Mexico eating a banana before the game
started so they should feel energetic
before this very very important match
not only in the tournament but in the
fight to go to Toronto
all right with the white pieces here
maximum
does he need to win this game with only
two rapid games in this match we saw how
dangerous Jan is with the white pieces
uh in his match against Anish I do feel
it's a missed opportunity and also in
the back of your mind if you fail to
even test your opponent when you have
white in a two-game match Sonny momentum
turns you kind of look at the next game
thinking oh now I'm gonna have to defend
as black my opponent will choose the
opening I'm just playing for the draw
I'm just playing for survival and kind
of uh your mindset shifts and it's not
necessarily in a positive way so I think
maybe a missed opportunity I think this
opening choice will be regretted by uh
Maxi version exactly the storyline of
what happened against Anish in the first
game right we saw the same opening uh
the Petra of a different variation by
white bear was the Petrov Anish didn't
get anything with the white pieces
comfortably gets out of the opening ends
in a draw and then with the white pieces
in the next game takes his chances and
crashes through uh so it's so far
looking so good for Yan and we see a
potential Pawn break on the king side I
would be hesitant to trade on G3 because
then you see this opening up of the H
line for that white Rook pinning that
Bishop on eight seven and even though
the eval Bar says that it's still fine
for black it looks uncomfortable it's
something that you voluntarily don't
want to go into there are these threats
of the night jumping from E3 to F5 next
yeah huge threat suddenly taking
advantage of the fact this is pinned as
you mentioned that Tanya you cannot take
this Knight because your Rook drops off
behind it and if you can't take it then
you will lose at the very minimum a pawn
this would be really uncomfortable
therefore Yan does keep the tension he
doesn't get tempted to take remember you
don't always have to trade you don't
always have to take what your opponent
is offering you I noticed a lot of
players when they're first starting the
game if they see a capture it they play
a capture often keeping the tension is
superior and he drives back the
opponent's Knight first of all
opponent's Knight drops back and now the
key question is if he's feeling
ambitious he might even push the pawn
further down but this will potentially
be a weakness long term the White Knight
does have one safe square and watch out
for the pawn stepping forward the king
coming over and this Pawn Behind Enemy
Lines might just drop off long term it's
really awesome what you're pointing out
because if you just take a look at this
position all by itself it's so easy to
miss a key detail that Maxim has done in
the last few moves which is provoke Yan
to push pawns and every Pawn movement
comes with it it's with its own set of
consequences and potential weaknesses
that night that that's on E1 right now
on the analysis board actually started
from D3 so it's done a bit of a dance
from D3 to F4 to G2 to E1 and
potentially will go back to that D3
Square shouldn't be a Christmas tree
a kind of Christmas would come early if
you get this kind of a position because
and it is on the board so black taking
some committal decisions which could
mean weaknesses later on 10 moves 20
moves on the line yeah I take it back
Yan did everything right until this
moment I feel uh this Pawn push again
it's AI approved it's Alpha zero
approved pushing upon as far as possible
but normally that's with Queens on the
board or when you're targeting your
opponent's king here this could be I
mean disconnected from the rest of
Black's Army if all the Rooks disappear
there's nothing left to protect this
Pawn long term and also look at what
he's done he's pushed his Jeep on
forward weakening a square next to it we
talk about F5 and how Knights will
Thrive there and right now white is
threatening to trade off Bishops and
then pounce with the black with the
Knight into F5 kicking back the black
king and suddenly things are turning
White's pieces look a bit passive but
they're about to Sprint to life black
has lost control over vital squares hmm
okay
big game big decisions to come for both
players they still have a lot of time on
the clock remember we do have a
competition for all of you at home today
where you can win David's new book grind
like a grand master signed by both David
and Magnus Carlsen and what you have to
do is uh caption this picture and share
your caption on Twitter or X using
hashtag chess Champs and you guys can't
you sign like a grandma because I've
already sent my entry with you
Circle I'm trying to come up with a cool
caption
my head's not working today so I need to
see uh everyone at home what what
captions do you have it's a very cool
picture it's taking all of my
self-restraint right now not to grab my
phone go on Twitter and check out all of
the captions but we've got to focus on
this game uh but thanks everyone I can't
wait to read those I know I know and we
will pick a winner by the end of the
show to get uh David's fantastic book
based on a chessable course that you did
together with Magnus and now you have a
book out there it's very cool David
that's right if anyone wants to learn
about end games I mean the last game
that napoleonishi won against anishikiri
it was a bit of a grind it went from a
sharp middle game down to an end game
once Queens came off and he kept pushing
and pushing you've got to slowly kind of
eke out these mistakes from your
opponent and
um just tiring them out kind of setting
these small traps it pays off Magnus
does it on a day-to-day basis I used to
do it when I was a more active player
and hopefully people enjoy and learn a
little bit along the way yeah
grinding like a Grandmaster it sounds
like that's something you really want to
do if you want to be one of the cool
people you need to grind right
is that life advice or just advice
both yeah but absolutely uh Cayenne so
if you've got the book here and I've
been actually uh grinding a bit on the
side it's definitely a book to get your
hands on if you're serious about Chess
Improvement watch out for Tanya at the
Grand Swiss uh very shortly winning all
these end games these long end game
grinds against but don't reveal her
platforms it's commentating at that
event and I have strictly told him that
he's only allowed to go to my game if
I've got a good
day's favorite I'll I'll be watching I
will be watching as well how are you
feeling about that event Tanya are you
nervous going into early looking forward
to playing a bit nervous but I think
more excited and more happy to play
because it will be my first tournament
this whole year yeah and I haven't been
playing several reasons mostly personal
and health stuff but I'm looking forward
to getting back to the board and I think
it's going to be fun it's one of the
strongest tournaments
uh yeah and David's gonna be there so
and I think you're gonna have a big fan
uh base there looking at your games as
well Tanya that's pressure I'm sorry
about that but David you've actually
said that commentating as much as you've
done over the last few years actually
kind of helped you when you played
tournaments you had some amazing results
thank you Kaya yeah I definitely feel
like the pressure's off a bit and also I
talk through the positions in my mind a
bit better than I used to uh at least
when I was a more active player when I
was just focused on playing it was just
a big mess I think a lot of the top
players actually say this they calculate
but they don't really necessarily
explain things to themselves and now I
feel that I've kind of got that extra
level where sometimes if I'm confused in
a position which happens quite regularly
then I just talk to myself I say okay
like uh White has a strong Bishop on
this Square so let's maneuver around
let's go trade off this bishop it sounds
simplistic it sounds kind of uh very
basic there but sometimes chess uh you
need that you need that uh kind of
Elementary stuff and yeah Tanya I reckon
uh if you play as well as you did at the
Olympiad last year have a shot I'm gonna
try my best and hopefully I'll have a
good time and I'm just looking forward
to playing so we'll see what happens but
what you said about David commentating
and then having a good performance it
was at the Grand Swiss Isle of Man
exactly same tournament yeah yeah oh
exciting so exciting gonna be fun yeah
and I'll be honest there's been a lot of
exciting stuff going on on in the game
as well and I think the bar is going
slightly up for a meal I'm really
impressed with what embryo has actually
done in the last few moves uh you know
David I've been talking about this night
and everyone watching uh you can go on
chess.com events and re-watch the moves
that have been played and focus on this
night on D3 the amount of jumps that
this Knight has done all the way uh
starting from move one David it went
from uh yeah maybe you can highlight the
part but it's jumped around this D3 F4
G2 E1 uh Square so many times and along
the way it has provoked Yan napanashi to
create weaknesses we're often taken in
by tactics and these uh aggressive
attacking games but this has been a bit
strategic Master Class by Maxine Bashir
lagrav yeah I'm trying to count how many
times he's moved his Knights and both of
these two knights have done a lot of
work throughout the game and right now
they're sitting pretty in the center of
the board and you talked about the holes
it's mostly this F5 Square
um the one thing white cannot afford to
do right now is to ever Retreat uh
because suddenly black would conquer the
square and actually this bishop would be
trapped in the meantime but right now as
long as the bishop sits pretty I don't
think black has many active plans for
example white can start bringing Rooks
towards the center if black ever trades
off on the F5 Square it's only going to
backfire this would be a check
and now white would be able to for
example step forward with G4 the king
would start going towards this pawn and
actually there's a clear path to win it
for example if black didn't just make
some random moves we can come around
with the white knight and now we see why
black might be regretting some earlier
decisions this Pawn will drop off
instead uh here fashion doesn't sit on
the position I'm slightly surprised
let's show what he did he took this
Knight I said don't move the bishop but
his idea is very concrete he jumps in
and suddenly black has to watch out for
Knight checks here Knight checks here
those white Knights uh playing some
important roles right now really
important role and that role is going to
be very very important if black starts
pushing that F Pawn all the way down to
F5 don't rush with that more holes
created with pawn moves you give a check
on E5 the Central Square that you're
pointing out and it jumps in further to
G6 with a fork on the next move so F5
was not a possibility instead
janapamnashi takes another route a very
good approach that taking squares in the
center so E5 is under control and David
I agree with what you said that did not
seem just rush with that trade going
ahead with that concrete approach it's
reminiscent of what happened against
Magnus in game three fully in control
with the white pieces in an end game and
then making that move with the pawn to
A4 which just gave his opponent enough
chances to get out of the pressure yeah
I can see why Maxine was tempted
remember he is a mathematician he loves
to calculate and he foresaw this
position he predicted it coming and that
white Rook looks like it's landing on E7
but the problem is after this Knight is
tickled and hit here it has to retreat
there's no time uh to bring the rook in
or at least I thought there wasn't
because of this night move but suddenly
I realized that Rook takes Pawn as
possible this is Maxine's trick he's
giving up the White Knight because he's
spotted but at the very end this is a
skewer and the black Rook is undefended
look at this weird scenario where the
bishop actually gets in the way of the
blackrooks protecting each other uh
suddenly Rook takes rook and wide is
winning so I can understand completely
what he's trying to do and in the game
position maybe this is a threat hence
why an apology moves this Rook up the
board and this is where stylistic things
really matter I mean a slower positional
player like me would have tried to build
up slowly improve all the pieces go for
them kind of go for the maximum and then
go for the tactics Maxine he senses the
moment and then he initiates the forcing
play and it seems to have worked out
this time really well because this
powerful threat of rookie seven
definitely got Jana bamlessly worried
he's decided that when The Rook does now
land on to E7 you'll have the
opportunity to move away with the Knight
and trade off the very active piece for
maxim and again this is a conversation
about the Eternal debate we seem to be
having all day long nights versus
Bishops but I think in this one for now
the knights are winning oh big nights
small Bishop black Bishop has not much
breathing space it's staring at its own
Pawn it's stuck on the back rank
definitely Knights here note how the
center is blocked as well that's where
Knights Thrive they really Eclipse
Bishops
great point in open positions General of
Tom's Bishops are stronger but if the
center is blocked and your Bishop
doesn't have that long range Power
usually Knights find it easier to jump
around and we see so many holes in the
position for black hair that the knights
have that power performance coming in
and we see them kind of dominate the
whole board and Maxim I like this
approach he doesn't Rush In which would
allow peace trades but what he wants is
to get his final Rook into activity he
wants to move that Rook from A1 to the
center of the board on E1 Yan uses this
opportunity to kick back one of the
knights but that also creates further
potential targets long term in Black
spawn structures
and how is black going to unravel you
need to somehow activate the black
Bishop activate the Black Knight whites
Rooks once the one in the corner comes
behind the other Rook Stacks up they
dominate the open file yeah it looks
like time is obviously you have to be
really careful the bar is roughly in the
center but it could spiral it could
Spike up in White's favor if Yan isn't
accurate so I think he needs to spend a
lot of these seven minutes the next few
turns
I agree with you he has to be really
precise to try to just detangle unravel
like you're saying because look at the
king side right you've got all your
pieces on the first and second rank but
none of them are in an active Square you
not only have to deal with peace
activity but also all these potential
long-term weaknesses with that pawn on
H3 which can come on the fire you have
to keep that defendant at all times you
have to make sure any King Pawn ending I
think is just lost for black if
everything gets traded Bishops Knights
and Rooks uh black will lose because
this Pawn will be an easy target for the
white king later uh it's too far
Advanced and okay he improves the black
king and now the most logical the most
uh consistent would be for white Rook to
double up but Maxim says no this rook in
the corner can actually activate in a
different way and again this is Alpha
zero ask uh very AI inspired type of
move playing on the flanks it was
computers that really revealed to us
that actually Rooks in the corner you
can activate them up the board doesn't
necessarily need to be horizontally and
he's trying to push this Pawn forward
even further and open this a line to in
infiltrate behind the black pieces so
black has to block you cannot afford
this to happen and now the big question
is do you explode open the queen side uh
Tanya you mentioned that Black's pieces
are so passive and normally that's the
signal that's the trigger for switching
attention to the other side of the board
black has nothing no influence at all on
the queen side and there we see just
below the board the computer does say a
very strong move right now Pawn to B4
while black is distracted with these
pieces on the other flank you switch and
uh there we go Maxim's working his magic
he's playing so well right now this is
tough
this is uh unreal stuff and what's been
amazing about Maxim's play is not only
how he's handling a dynamic aggressive
tactical positions but also these
strategic positional Maneuvers on the
board and this full board awareness of
creating play on the king side but
eventually striking on the queen side
and it is all about blacks pieces even
just visually when you look at this
position you can just tell all of
Black's Army on one side of the board
it's a big sign to try and create a
parcel on the queen side I think it
would be
to my eyes it would be a fatal error to
actually grab that pawn on B4 because it
gives white such a strong passer on A4
if black was to trade a takes B4 you can
perhaps
take back with would you take back with
the seatbon or does that create a
weakness on D4 because my first idea
David was simply try and create an a
pawn password by the way it takes B4 on
the board okay big moments and the
evaluation bar dropped as soon as we put
this on the board that's because this
Central Pawn would be weak Black's
Knight comes down to hunt it and
actually know what easy way to defend
this Pawn uh so he takes with the other
piece but I think it's more about just
opening lines here Tanya he doesn't even
care Maxine now about long-term
advantages like past pawns he just wants
to get at the black king I said it's an
end game Queens off the board it's never
in danger but the black king is
defenseless no pieces around it and if
white gets one more move to push forward
open up this white Rook it's sneaking
behind and this Kink could come under
Fire
that's that's ground muscle technique in
the end game right there uh you know not
thinking about bosses in the moment when
you can actually start going for your
opponent's king here you get your Rook
active a check on the seventh rank would
be absolutely disastrous but white
imagine if both Rooks line up on the
seventh Rank and you give a Checkmate on
that D7 Square the King goes to D6 and
we're coming to D7 would be the end of
the game yep that would spell the end
and how is black getting his pieces out
look how clumsy they are just huddled
together in a ball it's uh it's as if
they're just kind of hanging out uh on
the playground but the action is really
taking place on a football pitch and
um they're not yeah they're just not
able to join the defense I think Jan's
in big trouble and this is the type of
uh evaluation we see right now Advantage
for white that could again increase in
just one move and uh okay Pawn to C5
he's trying to force the issue this is
typical janaponishi uh he doesn't want
to sit passively he doesn't want to just
slowly defend move by move he wants to
clarify the tension but evaluation says
no Tanya because now I think you can
combine both the ideas that we've been
talking about right peace activity with
an Apon passer C5 striking in the center
if Maxime decides to trade those bonds D
takes C5 you'll have to capture back not
only do you create further weaknesses in
Black spawn structure uh with the Knight
I don't know you come back to D3 or
maybe to A6 by the way Maxine takes
another decision but my point was that
now you've got the B line to fight for
as well as the a parser moving up the
board
yeah this looks really strong you're
coming in via the B file you've got this
huge Target this huge weakness and this
would have been hard to defend but
Maxine does uh play a kind of safer way
a less risky way of doing things but
still the same question how to stop this
Pawn marching forward after this Pawn
much has forward you carve out this
beautiful outpost on C5 for the White
Knight also the Rooks can switch Focus
switch attention towards a lone weakness
here but he has to calculate suddenly
for the first real time in this game
because black has a threat himself
and I think this is the reason why I
felt that he has to take on C5 because
of the Z4 weakness that Ian now has a
clear Target on but Maxim doesn't care
about that bond anymore because it's all
about the queen side and when you have
more space when your pieces are more
active it's always easier for the active
site to transfer pieces from one side of
the board to the other side of the board
while for Jana pamushi to get his army
into defense is going to be a tough task
yeah
yeah bystanders they're just uh still
not
at all not contributing to the cause and
I think white is just going to win this
uh actually maybe even in the next few
moves Jan is trying to create some
counter play uh okay he's taking a Pawn
on D4 he's trying to bring the black
rook in but it shouldn't be enough it
shouldn't be allowed white has some
scary checks as well I don't think he's
calculating at this point he's just
desperately trying to activate those
black uh forces but fashion degraf he's
got this in the back if he can stay calm
control his nerves he's so close wow
what a start that would be for maximum
two the loser is final he has to win
this match and make it to the Grand
Final to have any chances of going to
Toronto and someone else that will be
happy right now is feducev who also
needs mvl to win this match and he also
needs to win the division two and
actually an update on what's happening
there in the winners Final in division
two it's gone down to Armageddon they
tied the match artemiev and fedosev so
drama in division two as well
okay I just love how Maxim has played
this entire end game uh you know it's uh
it's really quite a masterpiece so
showing the cake here yeah just amazing
chess this last move by Maxime it just
controls everything on the second rank
so he's not rushing with anything keeps
all his trumps in the position and Jan
really trying to get his uh resources
his pieces active as quickly as he can
now he's potentially threatening to
trade off that Knight on G4 and then
Advance his F Pawn to F5 to open up his
own files for the Rooks on the board and
David is he going to be in time to
create that counter player can white
start marching down the board with the
Apon knowing version that's what he's
calculating again he'll always look at
the most concrete the most direct route
first and use that mathematical brain to
work out whether he can and whether he
will be in time to promote this Pawn if
not then he might just take a timeout
you mentioned that Black's counterplay
relies upon taking this Knight getting
rid of the strong Knight and I think the
safe Approach at least would be to
retreat just drop back say to Black okay
my king is super safe no can't play and
only later will I hit you uh with this
Pawn push but yeah definitely both going
through his mind right now I think the
practical decision as the clock ticks
downward to be to move the night away uh
just to show your idea of the counter
play coming I don't think you want to
face the idea of these black Rooks
coming for the white king so you should
probably Move That Knight but he's
clearly got something else on his mind I
wonder if it's a check uh on C5 because
that's also a really dumb thing option
here uh to come in with the Knight that
the bar doesn't love it uh I guess
that's because your king just sidesteps
to C7 your Bishop is defended and you're
hitting the Rook so it doesn't give you
enough time to save that King side
knight uh Maxim does go with your
suggestion keeping everything under
control not allowing black any kind to
play again really instructive for newer
players as well that when you've got a
dominating position look for ways where
you really minimize any counter chances
for your opponent okay
yeah and uh The Rook move has the white
bar go up even further yeah it's
actually kind of it's like roll reversal
here and the publishi had the kind of
opposite side of this against Gary in
the last game it's just with a simple
plan you have a past Pawn you push push
push and the opponent has no active
counter Play That's How giri found
himself defeated in the previous game
and that's now the shoe that uh
napoleonishi finds himself wearing I he
has to retreat his King this is not a
kind of positive development for him he
at least he's clearing uh the lines for
the black Rooks to both blockade White's
Advanced Pawn but black Rooks here will
not be happy passive Rooks often spell
uh trouble
baby that A5 Bond will land on A6 and
the Knight will jump to C5 uh this is
going from bad to us a difficult
position for Jana Pam Nashi to try and
defend and David I'm just thinking about
the opening we had it was so symmetrical
right the Petrov it started with Queen
trades and thinking that there's not
going to be a fight not going to be
chance in this one
but Maxi made it happen he made it
happen and I think Jan can trace all of
these uh issues now back to that pawn
push Pawn to H3 locked up the king side
and suddenly it's white on the other
flank who's in full control that A6 Pawn
is going to immobilize his army White's
Knights are jumping Knights over Bishops
in this game at least uh that's I think
that debate has been settled and I don't
see anything active for black to do at
all and uh the clocks are ticking two
minutes each it's easier to play with
white as well as uh being objectively
preferable so this one uh not looking
good and also just an update I did see
in that feather save game he was very
close to the draw but he blundered a
piece in one move so he nearly won that
game he nearly clinched his spot in the
Grand Final things are just dramatic
everywhere I think the nerves are really
getting into the players because the
prizes are so big right now
it's intense and clocks are ticking nepo
down to under two minutes is there any
chance for him to save this game or is
he depending on basically a blunder from
Maxim think he needs a bit of a miracle
he's going to need Maxim to go wrong in
this one to try to survive it it's just
a full board domination here that Apon
on the left side of the board on A6 two
steps away from cleaning look at that
Knight on C5 there's pressure on Black's
D5 Pawn there's a long-term weakness on
the king side which the H3 pawn and also
black doesn't even have an extra Pawn
for all of these things that are wrong
in his position yeah if you're suffering
you want to have at least some material
to suffer for and something to hope for
long term I just like you say Tanya
nothing to hope for long term and Jan is
normally a quick instinctive player
he'll bash out the moves here there's
just nothing natural to do it's hanging
by a thread either your opponent will
push the a pawn to Victory make a new
Queen
or you'll lose some material it looks
like and he's leaning back that's not
positive body language under one minute
now as well wow
that will be an issue as we saw in the
previous game with Jan and Geary for the
clock will play a factor especially when
it's coming down to a race
that type of position
our feature chat everyone versus all of
napo's pieces I think that sums up the
position really well good one Sam a pawn
or the a pawn yeah it works in
everywhere right now
and or full blockade mode here for Yan
this is kind of Desperate Measures
that's not a happy move he'll have been
cringing inside playing a move like that
one but what else
and there was nothing else to do and
where's the Breakthrough that's all
Maxine needs to do he needs to break the
blockade of the black Rooks and then he
will win this game
okay what to do first I would want to
attack this Black Knight Black's Knight
is the only active piece so you can
harass it you can kick it away with both
white Rooks I think that might be the
starting point
yeah that's a great idea and The Rook
that I would want to kick it away with
is the A2 Rook because I like how the B6
Rook not only defends the A6 Pawn but
takes control of the sixth rank where
it's such an active Beast attacking the
bishop and E6 and he goes with your plan
uh goes with Rook to D2 because it also
eyes the D5 Pawn behind the Knight and
there's no chance for black to retreat
with the Knight because that would mean
you go into a material deficit so the
only option that Yan had was to
counter-attack White's Knight on C5 whoa
wow why why wow what a move this is a
really strange one normally a knight
Never Lands on the Square it looks like
a fianchetto uh a knight on B7 but I
think he's about to win the piece I
think Napoleon she's going to resign
there's a sneaky night check involved
and now there's going to be tactics to
end this game Rogue C6 on the board
tactics and it's all based around that
night landing on d8 with a check uh and
it's about to happen and I think Maxime
will take this game Jan might fight it
out till the end but
it's uh it's hopeless Beyond hopeless
two nights be a bishop we were talking
about that debate Knights or Bishops two
are better than one right now and white
has full control also the black H porn
that's sorry porn that we've been
talking about for ages it's about to
finally drop off Yan is gonna click that
resign button wow it's over free on the
palmyachi mvl takes the lead in The
Losers final with only now one rapid
game to go and that's gonna be a must
win for janapomnia
oh he's hiding there the Russian losing
this game that puts pressure on what a
game by maximum is this just more of
what we saw of MBL yesterday it's
fantastic it's more of what we saw of
embryo yesterday especially because of
the type of Chess that we saw from him
it almost felt like he strategically
outplayed Jan Wow Let's Take a look at
the game David yeah and that one
exclamation we both had whoa because in
Knight to B7 was a beautiful Clincher
and it was here we already established
White had the advantage mostly due to
the presence of this apron being so far
Advanced but the finishing tactic the
finishing flourish was spectacular he
brought his Knight to B7 this Knight was
hit by the black rook and now the
problem is Black's Knight in the center
of the board can no longer stay on a
safe Square no matter where it Retreats
there will be a nasty night check to
deal with it tried to retreat to this
square but the Knight was instantly
removed and this is based on this double
attack this Fork hits the king hits the
rook and after the dust had cleared
white emerged with an extra piece
beautiful and efficient technique from
Russia the graph amazing and if you
still have some popcorn left after uh
yesterday's entertainment go grab it now
because the next game will be must win
for janapalnayaki with the white pieces
we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things September Bots are here and it's
time for a Monumental Clash this the
ovarian might not Crush you on the board
but he certainly can Crush you with the
board speaking of crushing this giant is
a living Siege Tower usually found in
groups goblins are fond of sharp pointy
objects and other people's pieces
the battle hard in Valkyrie might give
you a game once she's done arm wrestling
a Golem
this hog rider and his Noble Steed might
give you a headache or two skeletons
adore her those fear her you'll need to
bring your A-game if you want to be this
witch yes that probably is a rabbit up
his sleeve or a huge Fireball with your
name on it we hear Wizards are pretty
good at chess
not just a killing machine Pekka loves
tiny butterflies but you're probably not
a butterfly so watch out
the Archer Queen thinks highly of
herself and for good reason she is a
skilled tactician deadly opponent and
your worst nightmare play them all on
chess.com
getting ready here for must win for Jana
pomyachi and the loser is final the
winner in the match will go through to
the Grand final tomorrow and in this
tournament we are excited to announce
that chestercom is partnering up with
the browser maker Opera we're so
thrilled about this collaboration it is
something for chess lovers everywhere it
truly puts the game right at your
fingertips no matter where you are with
this specialized chess browser and using
this chess browser Opera browser David
is now going to play bullet chess with
someone on chess.com
you won yesterday David are you feeling
confident today I won yesterday but I
did get a bit lucky uh let's see how it
goes I'm definitely inspired by the play
of mvl in this last game and here you
see the Beautiful the Slick Opera
browser I've got my chess.com uh
shortcut here in the corner I'm going to
bring it up of course you can play
puzzles uh you can do anything here but
I'm going to look for a game and uh okay
let's get a game going maybe one of our
viewers will be online to challenge me
yeah
um let me remember how to do this and
there we go
I've sent a challenge out into the ether
and okay I'm playing someone over 2 000
I'm in honor of uh Ivanka I'm gonna play
the caricon
okay this is bullet oh I nearly
plundered a piece
my opponent's trying to trap my Bishop
H4 a very aggressive move Tanya what'd
you make of my opening that was a tricky
trap right uh there and you almost
wanted a piece all over again
being put under some pressure here white
going all out on the king side we need
to get David A new mouse we really do
it's uh not the mouse though a blood a
bad Workman blames his tools and
whoa I think I've tricked my opponents
nice an attack now against the queen
against the pawn and C2
I wonder if my opponent's watching uh
watching this stream right now okay
that's a check I'm gonna win some
material I believe
and then it's time to get castled before
I blunder
and uh of course you can go full screen
here but I love this you can do two
things at once you can uh hide this from
your boss at work look
when the boss walks in and okay let's
jump that's a great life hack it's a
great life hack trust me it's not my
first time and okay he's trying to
attack me this uh this opponent is
tricky okay because I'm a grinder
because in honor of the book I'm trying
to trade the Queens
and okay my opponent's spending a long
time
this one should be winning now Tanya how
do you believe uh do you believe in my
technique at all
you're grinding this one like a grand
master David more like a grandma in this
one
you're trading everything off I'm gonna
start taking pawns good advice when your
up material trade pieces
slowly but surely
oh oh I could have checked me to that I
think but
or now there we go thank you for the
game David one beautiful there using
the new uh chess browser from Opera and
also using Oprah's AI tool Aria we did
an interview with maximum
thank you for taking the time to do an
interview with chess.com I have to tell
you though we already did the interview
with you using Oprah's AIA engine Arya
we asked it to answer questions as
maximum so are you ready to be
confronted with your answers
let's see let's see so the first
question was who is your biggest
inspiration and the answer was my
biggest inspiration in chess has always
been the legendary Gary Kasparov it's
sort of true but uh
[Music]
other players that I've been inspired by
and maybe the primary one was Bobby
Fischer okay then we asked what is your
favorite time control my favorite time
control in chess is the classical time
control yes yeah I got it wrong uh like
it's not that I dislike classic content
control
although I do believe that very soon is
going to be time to actually shorten
even the classic content control but
um I still would say Blitz is my
favorite like it has always been my
favorite time control and then we asked
what is your favorite open and I was
eager to see what it answered were you
here the answer was some openings that I
have frequently employed and enjoyed
playing include Sicilian Defense the
reload